hello and welcome uh thanks to everyone
for joining for this mini symposium on
julia in astronomy and astrophysics
research
we're fortunate to have a series of
speakers who each has been involved in
using juliet in their research and have
some highly side publications that make
use of that and so we're really excited
to be able to hear from them their
perspective on what went well what
opportunities they see for improving
things
some brief logistics uh there's a couple
of pre-recorded talks coming up first
during those you can uh open up discord
using the the
code you got sent with your julia climb
registration and ask speakers questions
during the talks as they go and and
they'll be there to be able to provide
uh text feedback during the talk
for for questions about
uh either the panel discussion the end
the the live speakers
or ones you just think about that later
you'll be able to ask those on
pigeonhole there's a link in the the
banner and uh most everywhere you can
find info about this seminar uh and then
you can go to ask your questions as you
think of them and you can upload them
and when if there's time during the talk
window we might ask one or two of those
then if not we'll be able to use those
to help see the panel discussion
sessions at the end
alrighty um
i guess our our first speaker
is mauricio tomasi
he's going to be talking about some of
the work they've been doing to use julie
as part of simulation pipeline
and i'll pull up that talk now
hi
in this short talk i will describe how
my team used julia to build a simulation
pipeline for lsp street a microwave
observatory
i am an associate professor at
universitat del estudi milano and work
in the field of observations of a cosmic
microwave background
this is the reason why i am so
interested in microwave astronomy
i've been a julia user since version 0.2
and as i have mentored several students
in the last years i have talked julia to
several of them in this talk i will
describe how my team has developed a
simulation pipeline for a microwave
observatory lsp street
i hope that visa will be of interest of
our people attending this mini symposium
to hear how young people studying
astronomy and astrophysics have learned
to use julia what do they have produced
and what they did like or dislike about
the language
so i'll first present an overview of
experiment lsp strip will measure the
polarization of one third of the sky in
the range between 40 and 90 gigahertz
the instrument is an array of 55
receivers
you see uh here they here
uh there are uh 49 of them are 40
gigahertz the larger antennas and the
six and 90 gigahertz
here you see at the border six of them
there are coupled with a telescope which
is shown here a sketch
next year both the instrument of the
telescope will be deployed to tenerife
in the canary islands
so observing one third of the sky
requires a welfare scanning strategy the
telescope will be moved
according to this
animation let me show you
so the idea is to make the instrument a
point with some constant elevation angle
you see here
and then it will spin regularly day and
night around within it for the whole
mission time which is nominally two
years
this motion combined with the daily
rotation of the earth as observed in
tenerife will make strip cover a stripe
in the northern sky and this is shown in
the right in green and blue
just the position of the green and blue
stripe in a equatorial coordinator show
you the sky coverage which is roughly
one third
of the sky
so we wanted to build a
[Music]
simulation pipeline which simulates data
acquisition so to simulate it one must
produce first of all 55 timelines
one for each receiver 55 receivers each
time lens lasts for two years
then once you produce these timeless and
you need to flag them
calibrate them and most important to
combine all of them to produce a sky map
of a polarized signal shown on the right
this map is not really what stripper
will observe this is a map produced by
the plank collaboration of course the
stripper will observe just one third of
the whole sky as i said
this kind of simulation pipeline
requires several parts
you have to simulate the motion of the
telescope and the earth you must compute
astrometic positions for each sample
acquired by each of the 55 receivers the
sampling frequency is 100 hertz 100
samples per receiver
you have to simulate the noise to
pixelize the sky sphere and to run the
map maker which is a task that converts
timelines into a sky map
this last part is not trivial map making
is a global optimization problem which
requires to process roughly one terabyte
of data without the possibility to split
the job in chunks all the data must be
kept and processed in memory at the same
time
so this task needs needs to be extremely
efficient you have to deal with large
amount of data
and to process it quickly
this kind of a
simulation pipeline once you have it can
be used to answer the so-called what if
question where one assumes that the
instrument exhibits some non-ideal
behavior
and wants to estimate its impact on the
scientific outcome
what if the level of noise is a visual
letter what if we make some mistake in
deriving astrometric coordinates
what if our calibration accuracy will be
something percent
a simulation pipeline can help to answer
these questions because you just simply
run it in the nominal case and then you
rerun it including the non-ideal
ideality you wanted to study then you
compare the results
we did not invent the lsp street
pipeline from scratch as we had a lot of
experience i had a lot of experience
from the planck lfi data reduction
pipeline which i helped to develop
planck was a space observatory that
implemented an instrument lfi whose
design was similar a bit more more
primitive to lsp strip
so let's quickly see how we developed
the pipeline for planck and then i'll
describe how we improved the idea
for a lsp strip
the planck lfi data reduction pipeline
was developed starting from 2005 more or
less the planck was launched in
2009.
it was a monolithic pipeline written in
c plus plus with partisan fortran it was
harder to compile because you have to
act the make file and properly point at
several mixed language dependencies c c
plus plus fortran
and plus it was a common dial
application even in the simplest cases
you had to hunt for its output files and
manually open each of them to check the
results of the simulation
just compare these with modern notebooks
it was somewhat hackable using an input
parameter file but for several analysis
this was not enough
if we wanted to turn on or off some
reduction algorithms more often than not
we had either to copy the main problem
program into a new c plus plus file and
comment and comment parts or play with a
preprocessor to turn on or off a part of
the code and then compile this copy as a
separate program
it was not pleasant to use it
when we started working on strip we
decided to avoid this approach and we
chose python as all the students in my
team knew at least a bit of it and
moreover package management is far
better than c plus plus and not the
books let one to work interactively
however after we started implementing
stuff in python
we found that my students found harder
to build performant code because if you
have to know the tools you are using
so the internals of numpy how it differs
from python lists how you use number
the syntax
used by cyton and soul
so at the end we implement the most
performance critical part in fortran
using f2 pi to glue them together with
the python part
however this was not a good solution
because
several members of the team disliked the
approach because now they had to learn
fortran and the tools needed to bridge
the two languages and moreover
zero versus one indexing for a raise
caused a lot of headaches
so in february 2018 we decided to
restart from scratch
and rewrote everything in julia 0.6
the first thing i had to settle out was
a proper usage of julius package manager
because i wanted the pipeline to be
implemented as a library rather than a
monolithic code
so um
how did my students uh
answer to
to visa stimulus i gave them um first of
all they um
with my amazement they were productive
in little time despite a few short
comments in the documentation that i'll
describe later
probably the most beloved
feature they loved it from the very
first instant is the ability to use
unicode symbols
paired with the possibility to avoid the
multiplication sign between a number and
a variable visa led them to quickly
translate mathematical formulae into
valid code and they really loved it
they were amazed to learn that
for loops that used to take so long in
plain python were so quick to run in
julia in fact for a few modules they
ported from fortran to julia the
performance was on the same order of
magnitude even in their very first
incarnation of the code they were amazed
and despite the fact that package
management is somewhat hard to learn
and
let me say
unexpected for a student in astrophysics
and the idea of having a library to
simulate the instrument instead of a
monolithic code helped them to organize
their work because each of them
developed the scripts
that listed the library as a dependency
and each script as a specific target
characterize this effect that another
effect and so on this led to a very
natural workflow and it was easy to
deprecate all the scripts while keeping
the possibility to rerun them when
needed
this is a point for proper package
management and versioning
and i should add that they spread their
experience and they still get several
requests from students for julia rated
these topics even today
of course
not everything went smoothly
because for instance the fact that we
decided to build a library instead of a
monolithic pipeline
means
that
they add to understand
how package management works
and
i use the word unexpected because a
student
in astrophysics is willing to write code
that solves
some specific physical problem
learning package management is something
that
doesn't really resonate with them but in
july is extremely important to
understand it
they had problems with julia
documentation
because basically
julia manuel is meant to be a general
introduction to julia why i
believe they were hoping for some
more astrophysics related tutorial that
introduced them to the
language or even if not astrophysics
astrophysically related a more
tutorial-like approach where you build
something that
is of real use
i should say that airing
preparing a new book for manning which
follows this approach and so
stay tuned for uh good news uh we were
respected to this aspect
and
surely and having a tutorial where you
do something astrophysical will develop
them a lot to learn the language
and
some peculiarities of language
more quickly
also because they started writing code
very early but
it was often not an idiomatic code which
missed the several nice features of
julia for instance their first version
of the code declared the type of all the
function parameters
which is something you of course do not
want to do in julia
and
related to visa after three years of
work i am still not sure they have
really appreciated multiple dispatch
unfortunately
and
i don't know why but
each of them missed the section
performance tips in the julia manuel
this would have suggested several easy
optimization for vcode which they had to
implement later in a code that already
existed i don't know why they missed it
probably it's easy to miss it
finally i will report my own impressions
about the task and how julia was used
for it so far i assumed
the point of view of my students
so first of all julia was very well
received in the collaboration it seems
that it is not considered a nick
language as most of my colleagues were
in tried by our choice of adopting it
i think that an often overlooked feature
of julia is a it's a built-in package
manager i mean
it's hard to learn for students okay i
already said so but it's so awesome to
let somebody else install dependency for
you in c plus plus it was such a pain
remember the experience in plank left i
described
um
i must say that
i've used the multiple dispatch a lot
but while developing the stripe pipeline
i overlooked the multiple dispatch and
it's manifested many times
even every now and then i realized that
if i used it in some parts of the
pipeline i could have achieve the
thirster code or better performance over
even both so
i the teacher i'm still learning
about the julia potentialities
i will add that
code llvm and code native are really
awesome to hand possible bottlenecks and
sure you can actually achieve the same
using a superfast compiler if you ask it
to output assembler but it's not as endy
as typing these comments on the replay
and instantly get the results
unfortunately i must list also a few
cons in using julia
so one of them as you probably ever
really experienced
on your own is the lack of libraries as
a matter of fact
um to properly implement the
pixelization of the skysphere i had to
develop a maintain
healpix.jl probably some of you have
used it
precisely because i needed it for the
lsp strip pipeline
and for astronomers there is astrolib
which at the us in computing
astrometric positions
it has been enough so far for the lsp
strip pipeline um
i fear that some time we might miss some
features that are provided by astropy
but not in australia i haven't reached
this point yet but it's clear by having
a look at the manuals that astropay is
so huge when compared with astrolib
so probably um
[Music]
it might be a problem for those who
need
more sophisticated uh astrometry
computations but that other
i thank you very much and the
presentation stops here thank you
great i saw that uh merci was on but uh
i don't see
his videos so he had a couple of oh
there we go question
from the uh discord are there any that
you'd like to uh highlight address
quickly
sorry
with any questions from the discord that
i saw you're answering some in text as
we went but were there any that you
would like to highlight for the full
group
uh well um
[Music]
i was still in the process of reading
all of them
there was a question about using memory
method files from you eric i believe
we didn't test it
probably it would have helped in
simplifying the code but we didn't ever
the need to save a memory because i say
as i brought on discord uh we have a
we are lucky enough to have a um hpc
cluster with enough memory for our runs
great
okay well i think the the policies were
supposed to only be talking the current
talk on discord um so if people want to
to move some of that to private
discussions or follow up um and also you
can move some of them to
a pigeonhole if you want to discuss them
more as part of the discussion at the
end
okay
so thank you very much
um our next speaker is christian
gilbertson they're a graduate student
here at penn state working in my own
group and we're very happy to have him
describe some of the work they've been
doing
hi
i'm christian i use they them pronouns
and i work with eric ford our mini
symposium organizer at penn state on
writing software to make it easier to
find exoplanets by jointly modeling
stellar and telerik variability and
extremely precise radial velocity
spectra
i wanted to lead with addressing some of
the goals of the symposium first being
how julie enhances my science as we all
know julie is extremely fast and for me
easier to read and write than other
canonically fast languages like c plus
or fortran which has made it really easy
for me to bring my own code and others
that i need into julia when i need that
speed for this project i particularly
appreciated the built-in support for
fast linear algebra with sparse matrices
with standard library components like
sparse arrays and packages like mkl
spars the multitude of automatic
differentiation packages and the ease of
benchmarking benchmarking with the use
of benchmark tools and flame graphs
there have been some challenges as well
the ecosystem around julia is still
developing with packages being rapidly
built and depreciated and when i do find
existing packages i often have to do
some tweaking to get them to do exactly
what i want
it is also sometimes a struggle to
convince other people to use julia i had
a friend at a conference come up to me
and be like oh hey i use the method you
described in your paper for the project
i'm presenting here and i was like cool
did he use my julia package that the
whole paper is about
they said no i don't use julia it took a
while but i rewrote what i needed in
python this isn't the first time i've
heard something like this
and possibly the worst thing of all i
just found out that my id has been
deprecated so i'll have to move to vs
code at some point which is annoying
okay so what science am i actually using
julia for
so i care about exoplanets when stars
host orbiting planets they orbit each
other about their shared very center the
portion of the stellar motion along our
line of sight to the star in other words
the radial velocity can be inferred from
doppler shifts that are found in
repeated observations of the spectrum of
the star
these radial velocities rvs can be used
to indirectly infer the presence of an
exoplanet
this method is one of the most
successful techniques for the discovery
and characterization of exoplanets and
currently the most common way to get
planet masses a significant barrier to
this endeavor however is the existence
of time variable features in the
measured spectra from both telerik
absorption and stellar variability
for example
there are pulsations where the outer
layer of stars oscillate based on their
internal structure
granulation where convecting cells move
gas to and from the surface of the star
and magnetic activity like star spots
caused by magnetic field flux inhibiting
convection at the surface of the star
all these phenomena cause spectral line
asymmetries that show up in radial
velocity measurements
in addition to the stellar variability
there is also spectral variability from
the molecules in earth's atmosphere like
water and oxygen absorbing and emitting
their own light especially in the
visible and the ir portion of the
spectrum these are often called telerik
in other words of the earth
features we can separate out the telerik
spectra from the stellar spectra by
relying on the additional doppler shift
we get from repeatedly observing the
star at different parts of earth's orbit
when we look at the simulated
observations in blue we can see that
while the telerik lines in green stay in
the same reference frame the stellar
lines and orange sweep across the
detector this portion of the doppler
shift is well characterized the portion
of the total shift we're actually
interested in is the point zero zero one
percent that remains after any
corrections for motion of the observer
relative to the very center of the
stellar system we are observing
so here is the stellar spectra
observation fitting or suf for short
model that we are using for what we
expect for the spectral flux at each
time and wavelength it has a linear
model for the telerik component which is
element-wise multiplied by another
linear model for the stellar component
with an additional matrix
multiplications here as the scene here
is the lsf matrix part to deal with the
optical effects of the instrument
because the instrument is not perfectly
stable which you can see in that bottom
middle plot with those wavelengths
drifting and the motion of the earth
changes where the stellar lines are
which you can see in that bottom right
plot
both models are evaluated a constant set
of wavelengths that are interpolated
into the observer's frame of reference
at each time
we can perform this interpolation simply
and efficiently by multiplying the
models by sparse transformation matrices
we also express the wavelength varying
instrumental line spread function as
sparse transformation matrices
while we could have used the banded
matrices here we found that sparse
matrices outperformed them in this case
being around twice as fast but double
the memory
so we initialize our suf models using
weighted expectation maximization
principle component analysis
this ensures that our models focus on
the parts of the spectrum that we care
about the most in this toy example
there's a simple gaussian line that is
growing and inverting in the middle of a
spectrum where there is high signal to
noise and away from the edges of the
spectrum where there is very low signal
to noise
if we do not include the uncertainty
information regular principal component
analysis in orange is unable to identify
the meaningful change that we care about
amidst the high amount of variance in
the wings whereas e-m-p-c-a gives a good
estimate for both the basis vectors and
the weights
the e-m-p-c-a method was originally
described in bayley at all 2012 and was
coded 100 in python
to get up and running using it in julia
quickly the first thing i did was to
just write a tiny module that loads it
in with pi call in this case it was a
pleasant surprise how easy it was
the only thing was that i was still in
the prototyping phase with my project
and for my problem sizes it was taking
about a minute to do each empca analysis
it wasn't a blocker but it could
definitely be better
when we found that our models could be
vastly improved by performing several
different initializations i didn't want
to have to wait around 30 minutes just
to see if my model started in the right
place
it used to take a full minute just to do
one analysis but thankfully a 10x speed
up was only a simple julia rewrite away
only depending on linear algebra and it
was surprisingly short just 100 lines of
code
another aspect of this project that
benefited from being in julia was our
gaussian process regularization scheme
essentially we wanted to add a term to
our likelihood as you can see down at
the bottom that ensured that nearby
model pixels were correlated to each
other as they physically should be
so for example this is a model without
gp regularization
and this is one with it as you can see
the high frequency noise is highly
suppressed typically computing gaussian
process likelihoods is of order n cubed
but several algorithms have been
developed to make it of order n for
certain kernel functions
indeed there's already julia code to do
this in temporal gps.jl
but the problem was is it wasn't quite
fast enough for our application
in particular computing the gradients of
the log likelihood with temporal gps and
the automatic differentiation package
nabla.jl the orange line was slowing
down our inference steps by factor of
15. while it scaled well much better
than the order n cubed as expected from
the analytic version in grey it just
started out too slow
additionally it was also not quite
calculating the gradients correctly at
the very beginning of our time series as
you can see on the very left
to this end i wrote some custom code
that was heavily inspired by the
temporal gps package that is built for
taking gradients with respect to the
input residuals rather than the hyper
parameters as you can see on the bottom
my code is as fast as temporal gps for
calculating the likelihood in small
cases and even faster for some large
cases
and with some smart precalculation for a
given model the blue line my method can
be up to a hundred times faster in this
use case
and thankfully calculates the correct
gradient throughout the whole time
series
a quick note on why we chose nabla
instead of zygote like flux.jl did since
we are using constant sparse matrices so
often we needed a package that was able
to treat them correctly at the time of
testing we found that zygote was
allocating full dense matrices in place
of our sparse one whenever they were
encountered which gave the right results
but was incredibly slow
nabla is able to handle this use case as
expected and treats them as constant
unfortunately nabla is being deprecated
at some point as this
funny github issue comment shows so
hopefully zygote can fix this problem
before that happens
to end the talk i just thought i'd
quickly showcase what all this code
leads to
for us it is impressive data-driven
models of telerik and stellar spectra
that can identify variability in both
our atmosphere and the stars
the top portion of the plot shows the
telerik and stellar templates which are
constant in time as well as the basis
vectors on the lower portion of the top
plots which control the shape of the
time variability
the bottom plots show the magnitude of
the time variability for each basis
factor at each time i've also included
the air masses of the observations for
reference the first set of blue points
in the bottom left plot and some stellar
activity indicators which are the first
three sets of weights in the bottom
right plot
interestingly the stellar variability
that sue found is a well-known stellar
activity indicator that tracks the
variation in the large h-alpha line at
6563 angstroms but it was found with no
prior knowledge of line location or
amplitude
you can compare soup's measurement of
the indicator in yellow at the bottom to
the instrument pipeline's measurement of
the same thing in red
suf models are often able to fit each
spectrum to the one percent level as you
can see in the middle portion of the
plot showing the mean absolute deviation
if you combine the information from many
sooth models together it allows us to
get rv estimate estimates that meet or
sometimes exceed those of the
instrumental pipelines whose data we
tested our models on
so with that i will conclude
thanks for listening and enjoy the rest
of the session today
hmm i seem to be live
eric have you said anything yes i was
asking you okay sorry i totally missed
that breath life oh okay i'm so sorry
that i just caused that much dead air i
had it muted wow just so i didn't have
to listen to myself i'm i'm sorry okay
uh
yeah so um the one yeah one thing big
thing i would like to say is yeah so the
en pca code is is currently kind of a
smaller version of the original python
package that only you know does the
actual
like meat of it like does the mpca but
um it would be really it's already like
basically in a module and it'd be really
easy to separate out uh it's just that
like
it's it's been a footnote to the rest of
this even though i i recognize it would
be generally useful
um
so i would be happy to do that if even
one person wanted me to
well consider that as an imitation
audience to has that christian email
um
another question that someone mentioned
was the the memory requirements in
python versus julia
do you want to
say anything like that here
uh
yeah yeah so the uh memory allocations
that i quoted um then both the number
and the amounts were just me copying off
what was reported by benchmark tools um
at b time macro for running them both
the the kind of pai call version as well
as my own
um so my guess is that since it was so
much slower i mean it could just be you
know python you know whatever slower
than julia but i also don't think their
implementation was like so
so much more you know brilliant than
mine that you know it was a factor of a
thousand less allocations like i think
it might have just been a bigger issue
if it's hard to track maybe hard to
track all the allocations through
uh pi call but i don't know i didn't
spend enough time to like really
investigate that
very good
um anything else
um
nope thanks for coming also i i realized
never said this but i'm eric's grad
student i'm not like uh you know
i i realized the last person said they
were like an associate professor but i'm
a grad student if you couldn't already
tell just by how i act
it makes your accomplishments all the
more impressive thank you very much
and our next speaker is eric agall he's
faculty at the university of washington
where he's been doing
some very interesting work on analyzing
extrasolar planets
and with that make it open up okay
thanks eric uh is my
slide showing up i am it's my first time
using streams yes we see your slides and
you wonderful oh so great to be here
virtually with you all
and it's also great to have eric ford
sharing the session as eric was one of
the folks that got me very interested in
julia in the first place
and i'm going to talk about some work
that was published last year
as well as some code that we're working
on continuing to develop i first wanted
to introduce my research group
which
a former student dubbed the eagle eagle
rhythms lab we build algorithms for
exoplanet transits transit timing
exomans and body dynamics
gaussian processes
i'm also interested in lensing and
binaries
um two of my current students
bethlehendor and zach langford have
bitten the julia pill and are using it
in their research
bethlehem for transit timing and uh zac
for developing a photodynamical model uh
tyler's also played around with it a
little bit with costume processes and
then there to uh
post backs and undergrads working with
us as well and using the julia language
my path to julia was secure this but it
uh you know in developing these codes um
i would develop an idl
which was you know high level i could
debug easily uh was interactive um but
slow and so then i would translate code
to fortran which was kind of the first
language i had ever learned
but that
the fortran took some time to debug
um it was also not as interactive which
made it a little less convenient for
doing kind of data analysis and such a
lot of my students started using python
so i considered that and every time i
tried to use it it seemed slower than
idl which was already slow
and i found it really awkward to use
these two languages
jake van der plast's first point of view
julia jake's uh written a
book on data analysis in python and i
was complaining about python to him he
said well why don't you try out julia um
that was some years ago but really eric
ford was the one that encouraged me to
use julia and and uh his numerical
astrophysics course notes were
very helpful initially in getting me
into the julia language
and about six years ago i had a hard
disk crash and decided i'm going to
fully go into julia and to rewrite a
bunch of per um program or software that
had written in this ideal fortran uh
mode
and you know it was you know easy that
all of you have probably been sold on
this but it's great developing and
with repo
easy to develop test debug code i'm
really not much of a programmer and so i
really liked that interactive aspect of
it
and then the justin compiler made the
speed not no longer an issue obviously
you have to usually
tailor julia code to make it fast but
that is something i'm still learning to
do but it was really great to have this
kind of one language solution
so today i'm going to report on this
work on this trappist-1 planet system of
seven transiting planets
several of which are in the so-called
habitable zone these are earth-sized
planets orbiting a very small star
and
with the discovery in 2017 of the seven
planet system we set out to try to
characterize these planets using the
dynamical interactions uh which is
referred to as transit timing variations
and so we carried out a huge survey um
with collecting 450 transits over about
four years with uh spitzer
was the primary data collector we also
use k2 and ground-based telescopes and
with all these transits we wanted to
look at the dynamical interactions
between the planets to try to measure
their masses
so i'm going to i'm going to have some
links to the code that was
produced for this paper which is in a
github repo so that's at the top here
this is using the piplot.jl
collar it
wraps the matlab matplotlib library in
python
this shows the data in purple and orange
with error bars what's being plotted
here are the transits of each of the
seven planets
two in each panel except for the lower
left which is one planet planet d
is of course the star
and what's being shown here is each
transit time with the linear femoris
subtracted and so these are the
residuals of the transit times of the
planets if each planet was just by
itself orbiting the star this would be
flat and it would be
around zero but you can see the
dynamical interactions imprinted by the
planets passing one another that causes
these zigzags you can also see the
proximity to resonances at the outer
planets especially on the right hand
side
where you get this 485 day
oscillation
which is
due to the
near resonant interactions between these
planets
and so by fitting these data
with the model we can try to back out
the
masses of the planets
we also want to measure the the size of
the planets we get that from the transit
depth and the goal is to get the bulk
compositions also to see if there's an
eighth planet in the system we know
seven are transiting there might be an
eight one that's too small or is too
long of an orbital period they've been
detected
um and then we'd like to characterize
the dynamical state see what that
informs us about the formation of the
system as well as characterizing the
star which gives us better parameters
for the planets
we'd also
wanted to make predictions for the james
webb space telescope which has already
taken some data on the trappist-1 system
and this is a great opportunity to do
some compare comparisons with the
terrestrial planets in our solar system
the challenge of this analysis was the
high dimensionality of the problem so we
basically have five parameters for each
planet we did a plane parallel dynamical
analysis with seven planets that's 35
parameters we also had
a distribution of transit timing
residuals that seemed to be non-gaussian
so we used a student's
distribution and parameterize that with
two parameters so 37 parameters is a
very large number to try to sample
especially for a dynamical model which
is fairly expensive and so writing this
in julia the performance aspect was
really important
typically samplers work well on low
dimensions you know 10 to 15 dimensions
is typical for the affine and mcmc
which uh the e-m-c-e-e package uh by dan
formacki is uh really widely used nested
sampling is to my understanding also
doesn't uh scale well with dimensions um
and the problem is that random walks
like machine micro are diffusive and
takes it takes a long time to explore
very explore very high dimensions um
this leaves a long correlation length
and slow convergence
and so the cure for this dimensionality
is hamiltonian
markov chain monte carlo which is based
upon gradients of
your model
my uh time is short so i'm going to skip
this slide um but i'm happy to share
these slides later but the basic idea of
hamiltonian markup chain of monte carlo
is you actually double the number of
parameters which is counter-intuitive
but you use
hamilton's equations to integrate in
energy space adding in the kinetic
energy term and this allows you to take
much larger steps and have a less
correlated markov chain
to implement this though requires
gradients and so we needed to develop an
m-body model which provided accurate
gradients of the transit times with
respect to the initial conditions
and so we developed m-bodygradient.jl in
julia this was a translation of a c
plus plus code by david hernandez
um
and it
does similar things to the rebound
package which is much more
sophisticated and has many more
algorithms but embody gradient we really
was the first time a code was developed
to take the derivatives of transit times
with respect to the initial conditions
of the m-value integration
now the gradients then allow you to
improve your optimization of the problem
and find the maximum likelihood but also
a lot of the competition that hessian
and then enable this hamiltonian market
chain
monte carlo
so with this code written in julia we
were able to sample this 37-dimensional
problem much more quickly i would expect
that if we had tried it with emc i did
have a co-author who reproduced this
analysis
using a gpu based code and using a
parallel method similar to happening
variant um but it did not seem to
converge as well and uh used much much
more computer time but it didn't do a
direct competition
comparison to that
in the process of developing this
project we did use automatic
differentiation aspects of julia for
some of the simpler functions which was
really helpful
um
and the total calculation uh took 256
cpu days on the cluster but from that we
got 6 400 effective samples for this
very high dimensional problem so the hmc
aspect
seemed to work
what i really liked in developing this
was the um as multiple dispatch
allowing to check if the formulas that
we were writing were correct and how
accurate the results were
multiple dispatch was great for this so
in computing the analytic gradients
we wanted to check are these gradients
which are fairly complicated formulas
are they correct and do we implement
them correctly
and so we used
multiple dispatch to calculate the model
in big float and do a finite difference
derivative and then check that against
our analytic derivatives and this made
debugging and finding errors in the code
very much more quick and allowed me to
develop the code fairly quickly
so the ease of calling code at different
precisions is phenomenal with in julia
this also involves just-in-time
compilation parametric types um so
this aspect of julio was really
great
the other aspects of julio that i really
liked in this project is the fact that
it's reproducible and open source so i
could share my code on github um it
seemed to play well with other languages
i use i use matplotlib quite a bit for
making plots um i really like the
readability of julia something my
students really like and sorry you
mentioned
and um i also was able to write my own
optimization but the levenberg marquardt
optimizer in particular and
i wrote my own hmc algorithm and julia
without a pit of the performance
and then the auto diff was great as well
we actually combined this with a
previous package i've written in julia
called limdark jl for calculating
transit vectors and julia was also
critical in getting high accuracy to
machine precision double precision um
there's a few problems and solutions
that are listed here that were
implemented in that project but i'm not
i don't have time to go into that
the great thing about that project as
well was that it was much very
performant in julia so uh relative to
the the the um c plus
um
code written by
laura crydberg called batman which is
widely used we had about a factor of two
times speed up
and then compared to another code that
included great derivatives because
lindark.jl also has the gradients
um it was also faster by about a factor
of three
we also found uh great speed comparisons
with other codes which are shown on this
plot and in the paper and so from this
we've got derivatives of the transits
with respect to the different model
parameters
and then we're able to compute a
photodynamical model for the trappist-1
system and from this derive very
accurate
radius ratios of the planets to the star
as well as the density of the star which
is
really diagnosed by the duration of each
transit
this river plot shows
in each row a single transit of these
planets this is just a model not the
data
and you can see the dynamical
interactions from the uh times moving
back and forth relative to a linear fit
which is uh what the zero point is in
this
the x-axis are in hours for each of
these panels and uh planet b on the left
is a 1.5 day period so there's a
thousand transits depicted there and
planet h on the right has about a 19 day
orbital period so there's something like
80 different transits
and uh and so from this we were able to
get both the masses and the the radii of
the planets
with the characterization of the star
then we got very precise
radii and masses for these planets and
the posterior probability distributions
are shown in color
the colors are actually correlated with
the incident flux or the equilibrium
temperature which is given by the scale
on the right
um if we knew the planets sorry the
stars parameters perfectly then you
would get these uh smaller instances due
to the uncertainties and the stellar
parameters and we get the larger ones
which are being flashed back and forth
here and i should say radius is and mass
are both relative to the earth which is
showing that green dot on the on the
dashed line
which is a model for the composition of
planets as a function of mass for an
earth-like composition
you can see that the trappist-1 planets
are all inflated they all seem to lie
along a single
mass radius relation and so there seems
to be a common composition of these
um this code is also available in that
julia
repository
i did run into issues with in using
julia so the allocations and julia
seemed to slow it down significantly
probably did a garbage collection and so
we made some effort into pre-allocating
large arrays that were reused uh in
structures this was
you know just
a little complicated to do and added
some um
you know definitely some
difficulty in the development but it did
lead to a fast performance code
and so it would be nice somehow to be
able to create some closures where you
could
use pre-allocated allocated
arrays without having to create a
structure in advance
we've also found in some cases that the
the julia performance uh varies with
system architecture we had some case uh
one case where tess passed in linux and
os 10 in the cloud but didn't pass on my
macbook pro and we're not really sure
yet what was going on with that so that
is uh one surprising thing that we've
ran into recently
um
the auditive framework as well sometimes
we when we have an analytic derivative
we like to be used to be able to use
that within an automatic differentiation
framework and that uh is something that
zach lankford's been working on and has
had some complications in trying to get
that to work um so
final aspect is that autodesk doesn't
work for numerical uh integrations and
um and can lead to numerical instability
due to the cancellation numerical and
skill uh or
um numerical round-off precis uh errors
sorry that was a typo there so that um
is something that is maybe just a
general
problem with autodev
we're also okay so future work uh we're
working on uh we've developed actually a
celerte jail which is now um
out of date it's it was developed with
an earlier version of julia and hasn't
been updated um so we could use some
help in updating this fast 1b gaussian
process which is probably similar to the
um
other gpu that was discussed by
christian
and
this this code is does have a jewelry
repo and some basic documentation but
needs to be
updated for the latest versions of julia
we're also working on something called
photodynamics.jl which is a marriage of
these two packages lindark.jail and then
by the gradient.jl to produce a
differentiable photonamical model for
doing inference and large planetary
systems
and so i'll end my talk there thanks
very much
thanks so much um i should have reminded
people that uh for these live talks
we're submitting questions via
pigeonhole
and
we have just a couple of minutes if
there's anything that
comes in
um you mentioned the
four diff or i'm sure you reported
reverse diff through the differential
equations at the astro informatics
summer school we had a couple of nice
talks by uh chris rockhouse and he had
examples where we actually did
run autodiff through some differential
equations so
to compare like
is it a particular you know feature the
differential equations or is it uh you
know which verse or which
other differentiation package you use is
the engine for it that matters but um
yeah i don't know the difference but i'd
be interested to maybe
try to dive into that yeah that would be
great because it would be nice not i
mean they put a lot of effort in
developing this m-value gradient
and taking um careful um
carefully into account the the
cancellations which can occur in
derivative formulas which leads to
numerical inaccuracy in some cases
um so i'm not sure if auto diff would be
able to handle that aspect of it as well
but be really great to be able to just
write one code and be able to use auto
diff rather than writing all the
gradients by hand
yeah very good well thank you thank you
yeah
next up is
zach lee
let's see finally he's going to be
telling us about taking gradients of the
big bang with bolt
and
take it away
all right can you hear me
uh
yes but you're a little soft so if you
can boost the mic or move closer
all right hello
yes very good thanks all right uh hi i'm
zach lee i'm a postdoc at ceta the
canadian institute for theoretical
astrophysics
uh i'm going to be talking about a
theory code for cosmology uh
which is actually what uh you know this
this will predict make predictions for
the data that mauricio tomasi uh is
measuring
and this work is done with jamie
sullivan and marius malaya they're both
at
berkeley uh so the general cosmological
uh program involves
uh comparing astrophysical data some
measurements of the sky for example of
the cosmic microwave background
or optical galaxies
and comparing that to theoretical
predictions
so here are a subset of the
einstein-boltzmann equations
that describe the evolution of
perturbations in the early universe
and bolt
integrates these differential equations
and
doing these uh
this kind of analysis lets you answer
really crazy questions like how old the
universe is
uh what the curvature of the universe is
it even can answer
particle physics questions uh turns out
the growth of structure is sensitive to
the sum of the masses of the neutrino
species
and at the end of the day you turn your
data into these triangle plots that
show your your bayesian posterior
estimate
so bolt
is
at a code for linear perturbation theory
and so this describes uh pretty well the
dynamics of the early universe where
things are mostly homogeneous
so here in fact is a transfer function
from bolt showing the evolution of
photons
in blue
going doing some oscillations
as well as the evolution of the metric
and baryons so this is a linearization
of general relativity
and so just a now lightning review of
this model that bolt is integrating it's
the big bang so it starts with some
initial singularity 10 to the minus 32
seconds
then the popular model is inflation the
universe goes through a rapid expansion
period
and then uh and if things are very hot
so particles begin to form during
nucleosynthesis you get elements
and then things begin to cool
uh so at the in the early universe
things everything is coupled it's just
one big party where every particle is
interacting with every other one
but soon different components start to
go off on their own
and in particular there's a special
moment
at the surface of last scattering where
the photons finally leave the matter
and then
they just
keep streaming on uh until the present
then there's sort of a quiet period
during the dark ages where not much
happens
and
then we get to the exciting stuff you
know stars and galaxies form
eventually 13.8 billion years later we
get to galaxies like the milky way where
we live
uh so bolt simulates the evolution of
the universe basically in this panel to
the left that is where linear theory
describes perturbations well
uh and the smoking gun for this model
has been the observation of the the
cosmic microwave background so here's uh
penzias and wilson
and
we get uh just progressively better data
of this uh
this cosmic microwave background so here
are three satellite experiments that
have shown
you know these anisotropies
and you know one of the key statistics
of cosmology has been the the power
spectrum of these anisotropies
so here is the two-point function
measured by planck
of the cmb temperature power spectrum
and this power spectrum is very
sensitive to
the physics of our universe so for
example
is our universe flat or is it open or
closed well you can tell based on the
positions of the peaks of the cmb
similarly
the the cmb gives really good evidence
for dark matter so the relative heights
of the peaks
basically tells you about the
oscillations that happen in the early
universe and sort of require some some
component that
makes deep
potential wells
and that's what bolt computes
is observables like the cmb power
spectrum
uh that is uh
predictions of the linear theory
so in black is a prediction uh by bolt
uh of the cmb power spectrum in
temperature
and
the bolt is the first differentiable
boltzmann code it also computes the
gradient with respect to cosmological
parameters
and so another uh observable of the
linear theory is the the linear of power
spectrum so this goes into the large
scale structure
and so here is a uh amount of power
spectrum from bolt as well as the
gradient with respect to parameters
so how does how does uh julia play into
this
so
the important thing here is ad
bolt is using forward diff
to obtain gradients
and this would be pretty hard to achieve
in any other language
because it is pretty complicated the
control flow
so modern boltzmann solvers have various
uh
they don't just integrate the einstein
boltzmann equations they have to apply
various approximations
uh at various times also you have uh
these fitting uh functions and various
other interpolators uh to make it fast
and so it's it's not so easy uh to just
write the ode system
so look really looking forward to
these next generation ad systems here
also the core problem here is solving
odes these are not chaotic odes that's
just linear perturbation theory
uh so
in this case differential equations.jl
is probably the best ode suite of any
language
uh it has just a vast array of methods
and they're all
many of them are differentiable
and in particular uh this problem is
very well suited to implicit ode solvers
the physics of the early universe
there's a long epic where the photons
and the baryonic matter
are very tightly coupled
because the baryons are ionized and the
photons uh just uh scatter off them
and that makes for a very stiff ode
system
so people uh work on various
approximations to to make this uh
solution this system integrable
uh but you can use an a stiff solver
and these have historically not been
very efficient for the problem uh
because you want to estimate the
jacobian that is associated with the ode
so using automatic differentiation
actually on the the system of equations
uh you can estimate very accurately this
jacobian and this makes implicit solver
significantly more efficient
and the ultimate goal here is as eric
was describing
to sample better
you know we the state of the art in
cosmology is basically metropolis
hastings uh it's it's the
sampler
used in i'd say most uh
beijing studies
and uh we'd like to use hamiltonian
monte carlo to do more parameters and
faster convergence and also for model
exploration using gradients to optimize
i would say there's a caveat here which
is that for the standard lambda cdm
cosmology it's very hard to beat
metropolis hastings
that's because people typically sample
over only a few parameters
and the the model has been very well
established over the last few decades so
the proposal density associated with
metropolis hastings
is very well determined
so i think this is a common story for
julia uh where it's hard to beat the
existing c plus python implementation
for the standard theory
but for new models
uh
volt is is very very good
uh also we have this vision of using
julia's composability so the vision here
is concise composable extensions to the
standard model
and more mixing of different ideas about
the universe so instead of everybody
forking one central repository
people can just write very concise
packages that
explore new ideas about our universe
also julia's package management is
really good
it's such a pain to get other people's
code running
and it's just so different in the julia
world it's really a breath of fresh air
another great thing about julia as past
speakers have discussed is the strong
correspondence between the code you
write and the science
so the
the dynamical system here involves
interactions between the geometric
uh as well as different components of
the universe
and on our right is a some lines from
bolt this is
basically
uh identical to the equations in the
seminal uh ma birchinger for example
uh
so this makes exploring theory uh you
know very luxurious
and finally uh bolt runs on gpu
so we want a sample faster and we're
solving a harder problem because now
we're keeping track of all these
gradients
and so we're also working on
developing
integration on gpus so these
perturbations came from a gpu
all right so now some julia gripes
uh we really want reverse mode
uh because
the the problem is typically phrase the
likelihood problem where you take
a bunch of different uh
inputs and you end up with one
likelihood
so in principle reverse mode a d should
be uh much more efficient
but
uh as perhaps others have encountered
julia's automatic differentiation can at
times be not very automatic
it's also hard to write efficient
differentiable code if you don't mutate
also
for users of python both python wrapped
boltzmann codes
those codes will have basically instant
startup times and so
using
bolt with its kind of long
pre-compilation
can be daunting for users
and then okay this is not something that
julia can fix but i love unicode and
i wish i had a
complete set of subscripts and
superscripts somehow it is the year 2022
and we don't have that
okay so just in a summary uh
boltzmann codes like this that solve uh
the equations of linear perturbation
theory are
sort of the first step in almost any
cosmological analysis so we expect this
to be a core package uh for the
julia cosmological ecosystem
and we really want reverse mode a d uh
we're working on this
and uh we're hoping for also you know
for the ecosystem here to advance
uh also i just want to echo something
that i think mauricio also described
which is that many cosmologists are
really interested in learning julia so
especially in cosmology kind of
computational problem is a very large
scale you really don't want to be
writing in python
but there's not a lot of subject
specific learning material and so i when
i evangelize for example i often point
people to the quant econ uh julia ebook
which i think is very high quality but
it would be great if people could
instead go to some sort of astro themed
tutorial
using concepts that they're familiar
with
all right that's that's it thank you
great thanks um and i found a couple of
questions on the pigeon hole uh one is
about
uh can we exclude the possibility that
the cosmic microwave background
radiation looks differently uh from
another star and that might affect our
conclusions
oh okay the science question interesting
um can we exclude is like is it
cosmological
i i think the question is like uh so
maybe from a non-astronomer like should
we trust the uh our view to be
representative
that's a great okay that is a that's a
really great question
uh it is remarkably homogeneous so or
rather isotropic so if you point your
detector in
uh
anywhere in the high latitude sky
uh you see this
background radiation at 2.7 kelvin
uh that is smooth to apart and 10 to the
minus four so stuff that is not causally
connected even right so opposite ends of
the sky
uh all exhibit this radiation so it
seems unlikely that uh it's something
nearby
thanks um another question how often do
you use unicode for for mathematical and
physical expressions in practice so we
we use it really aggressively in bolt uh
because perturbation theory uh has this
reputation of getting quite nasty with
the
sort of analytic expressions
uh but
the the bolt uh you know the functions
look so clean they're straight out of
the papers uh
there's also why i really want those
superscripts and subscripts though i
don't know
and somebody asks you mentioned some
numerical instability issues with auto
differentiation is that only happening
uh when you do out differentiation or
also when you get a normal
discretization of the
method uh so i i didn't mention this oh
my goodness the question just came in
but i bet that was for eric aegon
right well i'll push that back to him in
the panel sorry but so that's a good
question about both so why does bolt not
exhibit instabilities for ad
this because linear perturbation theory
is not a chaotic system
uh
we think that the evolution of the
universe the these perturbations they
they behave very nicely uh
at least for the initial part
another question about how the
development times of your code compared
to previously used languages
right
uh
i think in this case the development
times are are faster for writing the the
standard numerical implementations
but
one has to then spend time on these new
things like getting ad to work
uh or running things on gpus and so that
does take time
one thing i like is that kind of my
first implementation may not be you know
optimal but it's it's
normally pretty good right and yes
getting the last factor of two or making
other ad is
uh sometimes can be challenging it's
it's not nearly the same gap as in in
other high-level languages oh yeah
absolutely i love that uh you can
basically write out some math
uh and then also you don't have to
optimize everything right so many parts
of a code can be slow because they're
not run that much
but but our slow might actually be fast
for
if it were in some other way um and then
someone asked or actually i asked uh you
mentioned how uh you know there's sort
of this mentality thing one gigantic
like astro pi that does everything and
and someone has to maintain centrally
things
and and in julia there's a tendency in
the software development community to
use more smaller focus packages that
then compose with each other to work
well um do you think that that's really
limited to computer science sort of
software type stuff or should we as
domain scientists also be thinking about
uh migrating towards more focused
packages
um to build for each other
uh
wait so could you clarify are you
suggesting we build
more centralized big packages no i'm
saying if that's our tradition right so
a small number of big central packages
but julia sort of has this other
mentality at least the for the the low
level or the more you know basic
functionality of having smaller focus
packages and sort of asking should we be
thinking of going that way
as well
um or do you see it as being different
whether you're doing a
domain specific problem versus a very
generic type tool
right yeah i'm very opposed to this kind
of mega project uh i think it can be
very hard to work with
uh and also you know we're scientists
we're trying to do new things so
combining different blocks is way more
exciting than
making some small increment to some mega
repo
yeah i think that'd be great if we could
uh
make a little progress in that direction
um
and then the last one i'm curious if her
bolt you tried zygote
outside with enzyme vjps it looked like
the code snippet you showed was fully
non-allocating with mutation
and would avoid the julia run time uh
100 okay that that is what i want uh so
i've read those papers uh and it seems
like that would be the optimal
uh
set of uh ad tools uh
and also uh i mean those papers show
it's it's like uh order of magnitude
faster than some of the other things
uh but
so we're using these implicit solvers
where there's a bunch of blast calls to
do this newton iteration and so i think
the last time we took a look uh enzyme
wasn't quite ready but i mean that that
package has been rapidly uh developing
so i think it's it's about time that we
uh we try it again
well the question came from chris
rakagas and i suspect he's pretty
actively involved in that so maybe you
can follow up to help uh either figure
out if it's ready or maybe get help with
any remaining issues
well thank you very much
that was a great talk and thanks for all
the questions from the audience as well
um
next up we have
marius malia uh who's going to be
telling us oh uh
is that the right slide
the other one
oh sorry i see that's the live demo one
um here we go uh about financial
inference on the cmb
take it away
okay well hi everyone my name is maurice
malaya i'm a research scientist at uc
berkeley and davis
and i will tell you about um how we are
doing high dimensional inference from
the cosmic microwave background that
zach just talked about um
on gpu with autodiff and and all the
stuff we're doing
so uh outline of this talk i'm gonna
first tell you about the scientific
problem that we're trying to solve um
and then i will just get into a live
demo of the main package that is
implementing all of this called
cnblenzing.jl
and i'll sort of throughout give some
commentary praise and constructive
criticism of julia
and this talk is aimed at it's both
aimed at actually cosmologists that
maybe would use this and want to kind of
see it uh but also just that julia
people that you know are interested in
how we're using this technology that's
been developed so hopefully there's a
little bit for everyone in here
so i work with data from the south pole
telescope and the bicep instrument um
these are telescopes they're exactly
where you think they are based on the
name
and they are measuring the cosmic
microwave background which are the
microwaves given off by the big bang
and we use this to try to understand
dark matter dark energy the properties
of the big bang
you may be wondering why
put telescopes in such a weird location
it turns out that the
uh south pole is like the one of the
best places to observe microwaves for
two reasons so one is that the um it
actually is it's a desert um despite all
the snow uh so there's very little um
water vapor in the atmosphere this is
great for observing microwaves because
that makes the atmosphere transparent to
them
you'll be familiar with this if you ever
forgot to put water in your ramen
noodles and you put it in your kitchen
microwave and it didn't really work
that's because they just went right
through the cup
um
and also it's night time for six months
out of the year so that has its own
challenges um but uh
the advantages are that it's it makes
the observing um environment extremely
stable
so um
here's a simulated image of of what we
observe with these telescopes um so the
red and the blue spots are temperature
fluctuations that are actually only one
part in about uh ten thousand so this
we're measuring really tiny temperature
differences in different regions on the
sky
um for scale for the non-experts i have
the moon on here um
and then there's this little black pixel
down in the corner which you can maybe
see it's not a that's not an accident
that's actually if you've seen these
recent uh deep field images from the
james webb space telescope
um
uh these beautiful deep fields so that's
actually basically just that tiny pixel
on this map so we're looking at very
large scales
and this is what we see but this is
actually not the way that this image was
emitted by the big bang um
because that light was bent as it
traveled to us throughout the universe
and so since this is a simulation i can
just take out the bending and if i flip
between these two now you can see
kind of this this effect this is called
gravitational lensing because it's the
light is being bent by the gravity of
all the matter and the dark matter that
it's passing by
so you can make a vector field for
how stuff is deflected um
that looks like this and it turns out if
you take the divergence of this vector
field you get a map that looks like this
and this is almost to a great
approximation literally just a map of
all of the dark matter in the universe
projected along these lines of sight
um all the way back to the big bang
and so we want to measure this and learn
about the dark matter
and in practice actually it turns out
that this vector field is curl free so
it makes sense actually to describe a
scalar
field a scalar potential whose gradient
is the vector field since that contains
all of the same information
and this is this uh so-called
gravitational lensing potential this phi
map
um
and so this is this is in practice what
we actually go and try to estimate
now of course we don't observe this um
we observe the distorted already
distorted map of the cmb and in fact we
don't even observe this we observe it as
it's been smoothed by the finite
resolution of the instrument
and
has some additional noise and a whole
host of other kind of instrumental
properties
so this is a
essentially a challenging inference
problem we see this noisy distorted map
and we want to reconstruct these um
uh initial
uh these other fields and their
statistical properties to to learn about
the physics that we're after so just to
say there's some partial solutions that
exist this thing called the quadratic
estimate um
and it can be sub-optimal by like
factors of of 10 or so by the time we
get to the noise levels of future
experiments
our solution is based on bayesian
inference um
so we infer the online cmb this lensing
potential and and various parameters
um
so this is really this is not
essentially recoding something that
already existed but in a better way this
is actually kind of a new novel solution
that um that really only exists uh
for now in julia
um
it's
implemented in the cmb lensing.jl
package and um we've actually done it to
some small bits of data um you can see
just a plot here
where we um
we're using hamiltonian money carlo
sampling so you can see some sampled
dots there and some ellipses and and you
know the details of this aren't
important for this talk but but we can
do it and it's been done to real data
so now i want to switch over to the live
demo of the of the talk
thank you um
so this package uh cblenzing.jl um
[Music]
you can see here you can just import it
and a couple of other packages that will
be relevant so the basic building blocks
of of this code are these custom array
types that correspond to maps like the
maps we were just looking at
um so here's one which is uh it's called
lambert map lambert corresponds to the
spherical projection since we're just
looking at a we're taking the sphere and
projecting it down into a little
rectangle
and then i've put some dummy data in
there
so these are custom arrays that we've
implemented you can see they're printed
with some extra information
compared to a normal array
and they're just totally array wrappers
so um that original um two by two one
two three four um is inside of this
object as f dot r
and then there's some additional
metadata f dot prod for the projection
that says it's a lambert and projection
and has a bunch of
other information in it
so you might have noticed actually that
in the printing
um
the tube the two-dimensional map was
actually printed as a vector and this is
actually super
intentional and i think uh one reason
why this package ends up working really
well
and just the fact that uh it turns out
it's really useful to think of these
two-dimensional maps as abstract vectors
um
so much so that we hook into the
abstract vector type higher key so f is
an abstract vector
and abstract vectors are basically just
any object that you can define
multiplication by a scalar in addition
to other vectors and so these maps
certainly have this property so here's
another map
and i can multiply the first one by two
add the second one and i get an answer
now what's the advantage of this it's
actually mainly the fact that um
abstract vectors don't say anything
about how they're represented
so they exist as like this abstract
object we can certainly represent them
as like a list of the pixel values but
we can also represent them as a list of
the 2d
fft
components the fourier components of the
map
so here for example i swapped this field
to
be represented as its fourier components
and all the multiplication and
manipulation still means the same thing
regardless of what basis the field
happens to be and so here i do this
scaling in addition and i get the same
thing
and of course the imb lensing here is
showing you the result as a map but
that's kind of just an arbitrary choice
so as part of this we have to implement
broadcasting for these fields
and
if you look at the type for this you can
see it basically just holds an array and
some metadata
and we have this custom broadcasting
implementation
there's actually an example in the julia
documentation for array and character
which is almost exactly what we need and
so
basically everything just forwards down
to the underlying array and then you
carry around the metadata so this
actually works quite well and i think
it's something which would be much
harder in any other language you would
kind of end up implementing multiple
dispatch yourself almost if you tried
this
we can do so these are vectors so we can
also do inner products so f is a column
vector um you can transpose it and dot
it with another vector and you get a
number
uh and of course these things don't care
about what basis you're in you get the
same answer
now we deal with maps that have like
millions of pixels
and so it's impossible to represent
operators on these maps which would be
matrices and so they'd be million by
million dimensional matrices you can't
store these so we actually we work with
either implicit operators or diagonal
operators
and so we hook into the julia diagonal
type so you can put one of these vectors
now which is a 2d map but you've split
it across the diagonal of a matrix
and now when you multiply that by some
other
vector that's just matrix vector
multiplication but again actually you'll
remember maybe that f was a is a
diagonal in the map basis
but g was a fourier object so this
multiplication automatically swaps g to
the basis where it can just do this by
just point wise multiplication
so let me actually show you some not
dummy data um so here's kind of what the
code looks like i'm going to load up a
covariance for the cmb
and for the lensing potential this by
the way is exactly the thing that would
be calculated by the bolt package that
that zach was just telling us about
so this is now some big diagonal
operator
and if i multiply the square root of
this times some white
noise i essentially get
simulated maps
of the cmb end of five so now these look
like what i was showing in the first few
slides
and again being vectors i can do things
like take an inner product with the
inverse of this cf
covariance this is like a chi-square
it's supposed to be about
the number of pixels
which here is is 128 squared
and i can do log determinants and that
actually is everything i need to compute
posterior probability and and do
inference
so um for posteriors um
we want to define the model in one place
and generate simulations
as well as compute the posterior
probability so this is what
probabilistic programming languages are
for um there are several popular ones in
julia like turing gen
tilde
unfortunately none quite satisfied
everything we needed although i actually
suspect the um
more sophisticated one sauce might um
but we could revisit that
anyway we implemented our own actually
amazingly it was 86 lines of code so
it's really not a big dependency
but the way it works is that you define
a probabilistic model with this special
macro type this is how all of these work
so here we say you know some sigma is
log normal some x is normal which
depends on the sigma
and then you can generate simulations
and you can do log probabilities
and it works just the same with our
fields
so here
i've defined the noise covariance that's
going to add the instrumental noise and
this is what the model looks like this
is actually quite similar to what the
real code in the package looks like
so you have a f that's simulated that's
a normal a phi map that's normal you
apply the distortion that's this lens
flow thing you add some noise
and then you can do simulations you can
do log probabilities
um you can look at the simulation so
here you're flipping between the lens
then the unlens
and here plotting um the the on lens the
phy map and then finally the noisy data
autodiff so this is crucial for uh
inference um in this high dimensions we
use zygote for reverse mode
differentiation um because we have uh
gradient with respect to like a million
parameters of a single value which is
the log probability
um
so zygote if you've never used it it's
just doing chain rule through your code
so here's it is a as an example on some
simple things
and it also works on some more
complicated things like taking the log
probability um of our of our problem uh
so here it's doing a gradient um
at the simulation truth
and you can actually see that if you
multiply by the right parameters you can
see that this gradient already gives you
an estimate of of this phi map so things
are kind of generally working
but i will highlight one thing which was
that this was kind of a pretty massive
undertaking
and
um it required really understanding a
lot of the internals of autodiff and as
a quick example why um before wrapping
up i just want to show you
um the thing we run into all the time
here and so say that you implement your
own new type which is like your own
identity type it's going to be an
abstract matrix
and all you need is to multiply this by
some vector so you define this its
identity so just gives you back the
vector
you make one you multiply it works great
now you stick it into autodiff so say
that you want to do the gradient with
respect to that vector and you're going
to get an error that looks something
like this
and if you dig through this
this stack trace you'll see that it's
basically failing at a point where it
actually wants the transpose the adjoint
of that identity type which you never
defined because you didn't need it but
it turns out these automatic
differentiation rules need it
and that's the error
so you know even though i didn't need it
for my forward code i need to implement
the transpose for my backward code but
actually if the package had just taken a
gradient through the code that i wrote
it would have worked
and so there's solutions for stuff like
this um in chain rules it's called
macro opt out we we actually made our
own version of it before that existed
but we should get rid of that and use
the chain rules one
but ultimately it's kind of it kind of
feels like almost no ad on some of these
custom types worked out of the box it
all required work and i wish the
situation was a little bit better i'm
certain it's a really hard problem and
people are thinking about it
i certainly don't have a solution
i'm just going to show
basically we can also do this on on gpu
this part was awesome this part worked
totally out of the box so these
underlying arrays just go on gpu and
everything works
and i'm gonna in the interest of time
skip over this part where i show the
inference and just go to my conclusion
so um the cme lensing.jl package um it's
providing a unique solution that is that
can provide constraints that are 10
times better than state of the art at
least once we get to the noise levels of
experiments in the in the coming few
years
um
things that were awesome were the custom
array implementation gpu
the speed up that we get with gpu
is about 10 times and without that i
this wouldn't be possible
autodiff was a bit of a struggle i'm
really looking forward to defractor
which i kind of keep looking at um
because it sounds like that solves a lot
of these things that plague us although
i'm slightly worried that it seems the
from just looking at the github page it
doesn't progress doesn't seem to be
going uh quite as fast
and there's lots of useful packages in
the ecosystem for this kind of thing
sometimes there are limitations of using
them like the ppl library but we've
gotten a lot of use out of the generic
ecosystem
so that's all i had thank you
great thanks
um
feel free to post questions to the
pigeon hole i i had one about what was
it that was missing from the mainstream
ppl's that you needed to implement
yourself
yeah so actually if you um
i can put back this stream if you can
put back the i can go back here real
quick
and
show you so one of the things
um
it actually turns out it's really useful
to um
as you're doing this forward model to
store temporary variables that are not
actually
things that are sampled so you can see
there's if you if you had a keen eye and
saw this little arrow here
um you might have wondered what that was
and what this is saying is that you know
for this variable actually save it and
it's returned
um
in the simulation that gets returned by
um
you know by this this
forward draw
um
and as far as i know none of the
packages actually have something like
this
um and this was really useful because we
want to look at you know the online cmb
the lens cmd we just want to have that
saved before we add noise to it
um but that's one example i think
there's there's there's a few others it
might be worth
asking i believe in turing there's a way
to to save the output slowly but it
might be that you have an option of
either doing nothing or everything and
maybe
maybe i'm not sure if you can customize
like i want to save f bar
but but not a lot of other intermediates
but i know i've gotten
at one point trying to save lots of
output so
okay no we should look into that yeah i
would like to
get you know uh
use as much of these other packages as
possible sometimes it's a choice between
um
you know doing something quick and dirty
in 86 lines of code or or spending you
know time and potentially waiting on
pull requests to to make these other
other libraries work but you know
you don't know how long you're going to
need to invest
to figure out who else's package versus
writing your own might be a little bit
more predictable so truth always a tough
call to make
well thank you very much
uh our next speaker is william thompson
who's going to be telling us
about julia for adaptive optics
take it away
thanks for the introduction eric and
hello everyone thank you for tuning in
my name is uh as you said william
thompson i'm a phd candidate at the
university of victoria and i'm going to
be talking to you today about uh how we
are currently using julia for adaptive
optics on a prototype instrument that
we're building
i'm going to switch to my slide
so first off this work is uh contributed
by a lot of people in our group at the
new earth lab at the national research
council of canada
so you can see some of their photos
there and thank you all for your help on
this project
a few words about our particular use
case before i dive into the the dulia
specific technical details
we are working on photographing nearby
exoplanets
so this is direct imaging and that's
where we try and see the thermal
infrared from individual planets that
are still warm from formation as they
orbit their star
we first use a coronagraph to block off
the intense light of the star that's
this black
mask here
and eventually if we'd like to detect
earth-like planets we'll need to be able
to see objects that are 10 billion times
fainter than their star so it's a big
challenge
so in order to make this uh at all
possible we have to use adaptive optics
to correct for the earth's shimmering
atmosphere
the the principle is to measure the
distortion using a high-speed camera or
in our case in the near infrared and
then control a deformable mirror so
that's a mirror with uh hundreds or
thousands even of flexible
or evacuators which push against a
flexible membrane
in order to correct the optical surface
of the instrument in real time
so adaptive octaves aren't just useful
for looking for planets
they are really enabling technology of a
lot of ground-based astronomy nowadays
once your telescope is larger than a few
meters wide adaptive optics are
necessary to make uh to be able to beat
what's called the seeing and
make the most use of the instrument
so how does an ao control loop
work
so
we have a camera uh that is reading at
at least 400 frames per second and in
today's world perhaps as much as 2000
frames per second these are often on the
order of about 512 by 512 pixels so not
a high resolution like a digital camera
but
at very high speed
and then in the simplest case you just
take that image and multiply it by a
matrix that you've pre-computed
and then you send
the results of that matrix vector
multiply back to the dm
so that sounds really straightforward
why would i need a
even a programming language to do this
it could probably be written on an fpga
or something and done really quickly uh
well uh ao uh today on real systems is a
lot more complicated than that often we
integrate
multiple wavefront sensors so that's
cameras with their associated optics
there could be three to six different
sensors or even more
uh telescopes and adaptive optic systems
have thousands of degrees of freedom
we have lots of different loop speeds
interacting with each other
uh parallel updates of some of these
matrices uh people work on predictive
controls so using the past behavior of
the system to anticipate what
the
turbulent atmosphere is going to do a
few moments later we want to be able to
stream telemetry
et cetera there's a lot of complexity
here um
uh so unfortunately adaptive optics
which
is really hitting the two language
problem so these are very complex
systems and we have to prototype and
learn as we go
but unfortunately we
a big impediment to doing that is that
we have to write it in a slow language
first so that researchers can be
productive
and try things out and then has to be
written entirely from scratch by an
expert team of c plus experts to achieve
the high speeds and low latency needed
to run it on sky
so the current current state of affairs
is that yeah people often write loops uh
in the lab they test out a small part of
the problem
and they write a code to
perform those calculations in matlab or
python or often lab view actually
and then
yeah a team of experts comes in and
starts from scratch they actually don't
even typically share code often they'll
just write diagrams and
communicate those to each other which
isn't terribly efficient
so in our experience julia is not quite
yet fully able to solve this two
language problem but it can bridge the
gap
we can run multiple consistent two to
six hundred frame per second loops uh in
order to experiment in the lab and for
on-sky tests so we might not be able to
make something
a thousand percent robust in order to
run the facility class ao system of an
expert telescope but we can make it so
that researchers can be productive and
testing out their ideas and algorithms
so how does our julia architecture for
uh for ao system work
so we've written something which is a
trait trait-based component system
so each type can be a device it can be a
loop or procedure or a couple of the two
[Music]
so it can be a device that has an
associated real-time loop with it
these
components are instantiated from a
dictionary which is loaded from a config
file so everything is configuration
driven
uh there's a real-time gui which runs a
separate render loop this is built using
this great package called deer m gui and
the associated julia wrapper
and the gui render loop calls draw on
each component
at around 60 frames per second
there's a tommel configuration file that
is used to connect the components and
stores the current state of the system
and it's all integrated with revised so
that we can hot reload the code and work
on the algorithm while the loop is
running even
so here is a recorded demo i'm not brave
enough to try doing a live demonstration
of our
control system working in our lab
there's a lot going on here so i'll let
it play a couple times and point out a
few things so
each of these different panels is a
as a represented by a julia object uh
you can instantiate more one or more of
them
and then
a draw is called each object in order
displayed on them uh in parallel to this
uh several of these are running uh
real-time control loops at 200 frames
per second uh you can see that the speed
of the self-cooking camera loop right
here at 200 frames per second
uh and uh they're interacting to it
together and then in the bottom corner
there is a latency plot this is an older
one that's showing a latency of around
five milliseconds often we can get under
one millisecond of latency
uh so i think i've already described a
little bit of our architecture for how
uh how this works but yeah each uh each
object that has a loop trait can be
instantiated there's a management layer
which tracks uh which loops are active
and each loop has the ability to post a
results object from its last iteration
other loops which depend on results from
those
can then wait for updates using this
iterator protocol with edge triggered
events behind the scenes
so for what that might look like is that
there's a camera posting updates at one
speed and then there is another
loop component which is waiting for
those updates in order to perform one
calculation and then perhaps of control
flow branches into two other components
which
go off of that update
here's a little bit of julia code to
show what this looks like on the left is
a configuration file describing some
different devices and a couple of
different loops
that are set up
and
the the type field here tells it where
to look in the julia code in order to
build this device the julia code itself
is
not too complicated whenever you want to
create a new a new device or a loop
you create a struct to represent the
type
you describe what traits it implements
in this case it's a
component it's a device and a loop
you describe how to connect to the
device how to disconnect the device uh
there's a method to write out the
current status of the device so when we
write a file that's been recorded we
want to be able to dump the current
status of all the different sensors
and then there's a run loop function
which you have to our method which you
have to define
you can wait for updates from previous
loops and then you can post results from
your own
so a few limitations that we are hitting
i think this has been a common thread of
the day
one is that spawn can launch tasks onto
the gui thread so you can have your live
gui get bogged down trying to run
real-time computations because you
started a new loop
thankfully this is now fixed on a master
and should hopefully get into 1.9 there
is now an option to keep
a separate thread pool for interactive
threads
which we can keep our main sort of
survey or
supervisory layer
on another limitation which has been
something we bumped into is that
threaded callbacks from device drivers
so julia function pointers we write a
function we say what do we want to do
whenever there's a new frame from the
camera and we pass that into some other
run time
like the camera driver and that that run
time is going to run our julia function
and now if in that function we touch uh
we make an allocation or we do any kind
of i o even printing to the screen
there's an instant segmentation fault
this is natural we're running uh julia
code on a thread that julia is not aware
of it's a very sneaky thing to do
current workarounds are some
nice functions in the static.jl package
but it does appear that there is
progress on this front
this pull request linked here should
allow
functions written in julia to run on
foreign threads
transparently if i understand it
correctly
but the biggest limitation that we're
hitting is unsurprisingly that garbage
collector
so julia has a stop the world gc
that means that
whenever a garbage collection cycle is
necessary to clean up memory
all threads have to pause at the same
time
and this can take a while for it to find
a time so
when one thread realizes that now we
have to run the gc it pauses and then it
has to wait until there's a time which
in which all the other threads pause as
well
uh
so having any thread allocate means that
all threads even critical real-time ones
uh must eventually pause for perhaps up
to a second and this this really kills
our 99.99 latency we can run smoothly at
100 frames per second and then after a
minute
or two minutes uh the garbage collector
kicks in and breaks the loop for
uh ten seconds so what we're managing uh
right now is uh by triggering the
garbage collector ourselves at a set
interval uh we can we'd much rather have
know that this happens always when we uh
we've asked it to rather than a random
time
we may have to investigate splitting
loops into their own processes
but this would
be a bit of a pain
i think that gc latency could be
improved for this specific case with i
mean ideally would be a concurrent gc so
a garbage collector that doesn't have to
pause our threads while it runs
another thing that would help a lot is
if we could have an arena allocator
for
just the uh the real-time loops
there's one package that does implement
this but i haven't found that it worked
for our case
an arena allocator means that you sort
of pre-allocate a big buffer of memory
and then all the allocations within some
chunk of code just use up space in that
existing buffer and then it's discarded
at the end of a loop iteration
now the nicest thing would be allowing
non-allocating functions to continue
while the garbage collector runs so if
our hard real-time loops could uh could
continue all the while that uh
that um
the gui thread uh is running and this is
sort of impossible to avoid allocations
in the gui thread because you need to
for example format a string to describe
what the current uh status of the system
is
so i think i'm actually a little bit
quick but in summary so julia for
adaptive optics it's a great way to move
very fast and get algorithms working on
sky uh some tricky issues are getting
fixed in july 1.9
but gc latency does mean that july does
not yet solve the two language problem
it means you know we can uh
it works great for the prototyping phase
up to the point of even controlling uh
uh prototype instruments but it can't
yet take the place of a team of c
programmers writing a real-time
system
thank you
great thanks
um
um i had a question are you running this
on a real-time linux or is it a generic
one
we run this uh you know at least in the
testing phase on all different platforms
because it's nice to be able to test it
on your laptop uh so we run it on mac
and windows and so on but then for the
the real device we're writing it or
we're running it on a real-time patch of
the ubuntu
server
and you mentioned sort of the tradeoff
of having every thread running at once
uh versus
uh
i'm wondering is there way you could
have like all the the low level threads
in one kernel communicate through some
channel to a gui
uh thread that did the gui alone
yeah it's a great question and and uh or
a great suggestion and something that
we're thinking about is having to sort
of have that process boundary between
the things that have to be fast and the
things that don't have to be fast uh we
we may have to do that it's not ideal
because now it's uh
well it's just a lot of work to
synchronize and you know and and deal
with the code base that involves
multiple different processes that all
have to be started instead of
communication and things but probably
that's what we'll eventually have to do
i mean i think there probably are other
applications you know whether it's web
servers or or gui's that have a similar
design need and so there might be
something that you could reuse there but
maybe some of the listeners can chime in
with a suggestion on the pigeon hole
great well thanks for for that um next
up we'll have paul barrett who's going
to talk to us about analyzing radio
astronomy data and for those who don't
know
paul has the distinction of being one of
the people who is instrumental in
getting astronomers to switch away from
iraf and idl um
unfortunately it was a few decades ago
and so it was to python which now some
of us are are sort of in the middle of
trying to navigate the next transition
so i think he'll be a great person to
ask some questions about uh in the panel
for ideas of how we can make that next
transition but first uh tell us about
radio astronomy
oh i don't hear you paul uh you're muted
i'm i can unmute you how about that
again
you're not muted but you're very soft is
there something you can have any
switching microphones or moving clothes
or anything
okay
um
gonna try again
how's that excellent thanks all right
wrong microphone
sorry about that
um
to start over again i'm paul barrett the
associate research professor at the
george washington university
uh current interest now is radio
astronomy so my talk is back to basics
and analyzing radio astronomy data
let's see if i can
so the outline here is
talk about radio interferometers the vla
historical background different types of
analysis synthesize
synthetic imaging and visibility
analysis the type of research that i do
magnetic cataclysmic variables
radio observations and the motivation
for writing
this software called this fit
so radio interferometers are basically
uh they're effective apertures
their longest baseline is the effect of
aperture is the longest baseline between
antennas
the way the work they work is the they
take the amplitude from each antenna and
they correlate it
and this is called visibility data
the noise associated with this data is
gaussian
typically
and so an example of
you know
a radio interferometer a
radio motor ferometer is the uh carl g
jams can very large array the vla out in
socorro new mexico
it has 27 antennas or basically 357
51 correlations
um
each antenna has
anywhere from 1024 to 4096 spectral
channels
and uh integration times are any
anywhere from two to five seconds uh two
seconds when you're dealing with higher
frequencies of 10 20 gigahertz or so on
so uh the amount of data you can get out
can be anywhere from
you know for one hour
be 10 gigabytes up to a terabyte if
you're working at really high
frequencies
so it's a lot of data that one has to
deal with
so historically because of that
well early on more than 50 years ago
when you only had a small number of
baselines two or three
you actually used what i call the
visibility data the raw data to to work
with them
but as the data volumes increased and
you got more baselines and wider
bandwidths
that became a problem because processors
were slow then
um
so
less than about 50 years ago they
switched over to synthetic imaging a lot
of people were doing image type analysis
the vla was coming online
and uh
so
to create these maps and a lot of people
were looking at diffuse sources uh they
switched over to using the fast fourier
transform
to create images and one way to detect
the source is what the this
algorithm called the clean algorithm
so uh and that right now is considered
this the orthodox way of you know
analyzing radio astronomy data
and not the visibility analysis
so in terms of synthetic imaging the
pros is you know it's an orthodox
technique people have been working on it
for 40 50 years now
it has good performance for slow
processors and small amounts of memories
some of the cons though is
when you do an fft you're correlating
noise across
samples and uh and the other aspect is
you're also providing signal aliasing
okay so you can actually take a a signal
or a source from outside the field of
view and you can bring it into the field
of view not something you really want to
do
a negative with a clean algorithm is it
doesn't really have a rigorous stopping
criteria so
things aren't really completely
predictable okay or reproducible
in terms of the current software we have
out there the national radio astronomy
observatory has software called casa
casa
and it's written in c plus and has a
python wrapper around it
it's
30 40 years old now and so it's really
not highly optimized for today's
processors
and so
the whole
technique and whole co issue with
particularly with casa is the auto the
analysis is still predicated on manual
analysis or semi-automatic analysis and
not fully automatic
now one way to get around that
these issues is to think about
looking at the raw visibility data
and the pros there is you know
the noise is uncorrelated
you know you're working with gaussian
noise
if you're using optimization algorithms
those have rigorous stopping criteria
so they're accurate they're reproducible
and if you work the algorithms properly
you can get the fairly high performance
and of course the big
issue that i worked on is i want to do
this automatically i don't want to do
data analysis manually or semi-on
semi-manual semi-automatically
the cons to this is it's an unorthodox
technique people don't really think that
it's worthwhile nowadays
and the other issue is it can be
potentially computationally intensive
so the motivation for this is uh the
work that i do i work with magnetic
cataclysmic variables
uh they're interacting binary stars
with uh
with orbital periods of 80 minutes to 12
hours sometimes a bit more
the primary component is a white dwarf
with a mass of 0.6 to 1.2 solar masses
and
they have the white dwarf has a strong
magnetic field anywhere from 10 to 240
mega gallons
um its companion is a late type star of
0.15 to 0.5 solar masses
and
since the order appears are so short um
the companion has rochelle overflow and
basically
provides matter um
basically the white dwarf accretes
matter
um from the companion star
and the magnetic field is so strong
that
instead of an accretion disk forming
which is usually what happens you get an
accretion column and there's an example
an artist rendition of what a magnetic
cataclysmic variable might look like
and then you can see the accretion
columns and the threading regions and so
on
so i do radio observations of these
here's an example of
observation
the image on the left is the right
circularly polarized feed and the image
on the right is the left circularly
polarized feed
as you notice these are point sources
um and you can also see
they they can be highly circularly
polarized basically this object is 100
circularly polarized
so
the other aspect of these sources is
they're highly variable um flex density
they can change their flux densities by
more than 10 times
so
all of these issues come to
come down to i don't really need to do
imaging what i need to do is
photo spectropolarity i need to do time
series analysis
of spectroscopic and polar metric data
and so i'm working with the stokes
parameters
i is the intensity q u or linear
polarizations orthogonal polarizations
v is a circular polarization
or
more accurately i work with the r
channel rr and ll channel the left and
right circularly polarized channels
so there's a picture here it's not a uh
time series analysis it's actually a
spectrum
in what you see is that the
the blue
the blue samples or blue periods are
actually the left circular polarization
and the red ones are the right circular
polarization you can see that the
spectrum varies
not consistently
kind of randomly and it's a pretty much
100 percent circularly polarized
so um the motivation for riding vis fits
is that
currently now i have probably over 100
terabytes of data that i need to go
through i've got a large volume of data
and the current software analysis um
is just too slow uh
it you know i believe it can be done
faster you can be automated
and as i go back to it synthetic imaging
is not statistically rigorous
because of this
issue with correlated errors it's not
reproducible because the clean algorithm
it's actually less sensitive
okay
and
because i have to make images and
typically those images kind of have to
be made
manually or semi manually
semi-automatic uh it's slow it will take
me two to three days to generate
tens to 100 you know images which i need
to do so
i need to come up with something that's
a little more efficient automated and
visibility analysis is the approach i've
taken um
did you see there you know it's
statistically rigorous it's reproducible
and the big positive aspect is it's 20
more sensitive
and that's a big key because a lot of my
sources
are four and five sigma uh type
detections right on the limit
so if i get a five sigma detection
you know out of a visibility analysis
in the synthetic image it's a four
segment it becomes marginal
but you know if i can make it five sigma
then i can say that i'm fairly certain
there's a source there
so i went back and i looked at
what was out there this slide might be a
bit difficult to see but there's about
seven or eight uh different
applications out there that one can use
to do visibility fitting
and
the big one is there's the one that
comes with the casa is called uv
multi-fit it has limitations
there's a more modern one called
um
uv
multi-fit not me is the more modern one
uv model fit is the older one
but just just of it is they all have
certain limitations and
a lot of them are written in fortran
you have to use the the various data
analysis environments like gildas is
different than myriad
so you have to learn those various data
analysis environments
others are written in fortran and c
it's just kind of a mess so i decided
that i would use julia to
write my own
package and try to make it
the best package that's out there
basically
provide different shapes
that you can use you can fit a delta
function or a gaussian or
an annulus or whatever you can use you
know multiple sources
you can fit
all the stokes parameters or left and
right circular polarization channels
you can do you can fit the spectral at
index simultaneously or that type of
aspect so
the idea is to just make a very general
purpose
and so
i've spent about it
been working on this for over a year now
called vis-fit off and on
benefit of using julia is you don't have
to write a sub language
so uv multi-fib
which is
uh
it's underlying code is c plus plus but
it has a python wrapper
it also has a sub language the person
has to write a language so that when you
enter a model
it understands what that model means
because that has to be transferred into
the underlying c plus code
julia you don't need that you just write
julia code here's an example the base
model which is a delta function
and the intensity and it's just that
simple it's a single
you know just a single line of code
[Music]
the other aspect i wanted to do is i
wanted to uh
fit
you know the i this four stokes
parameters iq uv simultaneously
for a particular position or i want to
look at the the left and right circular
polarizations just at a particular
position simultaneously a number of
those packages that don't allow that you
can only fit
one parameter at a time
and the other example is enables
frequency models there's a example here
where there's a gaussian model
and
you can probably see that there new is
the
frequency
and
new to the seven is basically the
spectral index so
that uh
you know you can do it that way
the one benefit of this is
an aspect i've been working on is making
it multi-threaded
and that's provided a huge improvement
in the performance
uh for some simple data
i can get an answer out i can generate a
light curve in less than 30 minutes
whereas normally it took me you know one
two or three days to do to do this
so it really improved the amount of
research that i can get done
future developments it's still this
package still isn't out in the public i
haven't made it public i don't want
to put it out there and have to answer
lots of questions
so when it gets to that point where i
feel safe that
you know
it's ready to become public i will make
it public
the one thing i want to add
and i've been working on is data
selection and iteration so if i want to
make this automatic i want to be able to
say okay
give me uh the intensity
of this object you know every 30 seconds
or every 60 seconds
on at between these frequencies and so
on so
uh there's a lot of options you can do
in terms of selecting the data that you
want to to generate a light curve of or
a spectrum of
and uh
and you want to be able to iterate
through that
so once that's pretty much complete and
i'm happy with you know that
implementation i'll make it available
additional implement future developments
for general constraints right now i just
use a simple 11 bar marquardt algorithm
with box constraints
i'd like to make that more generalizable
there's other aspects of
radio astronomy data that you can take
advantage of
between the various antennas you can
have what they call called closure
phases and closure amplitudes
that data is available it should be used
because it will give you much better
results
the big aspect of
radio data is radio frequency
interference and
the l2 norm you know
you know means you know square type of
analysis uh
doesn't do well with outlier data so one
way to mitigate that is to use an l1
norm
i'm planning on looking into that
and then the other aspect is to
instead of doing local
optimization is to use an algorithm that
provides global optimization when
one of those algorithms is the method of
moving asymptotes which i'm interested
in so
um
the idea is to make this generally
available to people um
over time to the astronomical community
which i think would be a great advantage
and
you know the big benefits are
improved sensitivity and potentially
faster analysis
that's all i have to say thank you
great thanks
um
let's see i didn't see any questions
specific to this talk yet
um
bro here we go uh refreshing uh do you
have access to data calibration
can you also solve for right left gains
and d terms
uh what's that i'm sorry what's that so
they asked do you have access to data
calibration can you also
solve for right left gains and d
determines
no i don't do that right now that would
be something to to do in the future
i'm still
i'm still using the uh the vla the casa
uh standard calibration pipeline to do
all that work right now
um the cost is rather slow and it would
be nice to expand this eventually to
to actually do you know
uh duplicate the cost of calibration
pipeline i think it would be done much
more quickly probably in about
a third to five you know the fifth
amount of time
and much more accurately
great
thanks well that's a perfect timing um
and so why don't people uh move over to
the pigeon hole for questions and i will
uh pull up my own screen
with
uh let's see
share
share screen
here we go
so here's the questions uh that have
been upvoted so far
so and let me let me add all the
panelists back to we'll get a big group
discussion
uh
wearing the panelists your video is
about to be shared
all right
i guess we can do a big
so the first question
we have is what additions or upgrades
the julia package ecosystem do you think
would be helpful for accelerating the
adoption of julia amongst the the
broader astronomical community so uh
suggestions
uh ideas in the panel
i can uh take a
quick sabotage
a little bit self-promotion but uh there
is a julia astro working group call that
some of us are on i would meet about
once a month and one of the things that
we've been working on is a package
called astro images which is designed to
take the
most basic step in astronomy data
reduction uh working with uh images
straight from the telescope and fix
files and things like that making that
much easier for beginners to
sink their teeth into
that is sort of one little tiny corner
of what astro pi can do
so hopefully some other little corners
of that can also be bitten off by other
groups of people and over time we can
have all of it covered but
that's sort of one of the first things
that
we've been looking at
i'd like to add that we're also
trying to duplicate the
novas which is the naval observatory
vector
astrometry package so that you can do
procession and mutation and that type of
stuff
and do it for um
no mass is actually quite slow because
of the way it's implemented
and the idea would be to make this uh
you know vectorizable so you can do
millions or billions
of stars or whatever at once you know
very quickly so
uh eric ago in the discussion i noticed
uh you had some comments about the
reverse or the different auto
differentiation tools and it wasn't so
much that they didn't work it was that
you needed a high precision and
sometimes we had complex expressions
that the compilers generated uh very
large trees that had ran off air and
stuff so i wonder uh if that might be an
area that is almost abstractive away
from astronomy even but that might allow
more widespread use in scientific
context with some
complex expressions
yeah that's a great comment uh i
i don't know
of any work being done in that direction
but it probably it might involve
symbolic computation because a lot of
times i found that i could you know
cancel terms in my analytic derivatives
that you know didn't appear to be
canceling in the auto diff and and that
seemed to generate round off for
numerical error
so um but it's not something i pursued
yet i just
did it for this one package
yeah um just uh just to chime in i also
had a similar experience when for for a
previous julia package i was trying to
get like you know analytic hessian
expressions um and
you know those obviously blow up quite
quickly uh once you take more and more
derivatives but yeah there was like
you know i think um there were lots of
terms that like you know i had like
custom little rules like to string
replace like 0.0 plus whatever or you
know 1.0 times or any you know plus this
term minus this term like it might just
be an
annoying problem to generically tackle
but one i think that that might have to
be at a symbolic level rather than a
just so it can recognize that this is
exactly equal to that
but yeah that's that sounds useful
and then there was another question
later on about the possibility of
translating parts or maybe even all of
astro pi
um and
and there were some comments about you
know maybe
maybe it doesn't make sense to translate
all but what are the different speakers
views on
uh what sort of astronomy specific
routines or or infrastructure we might
uh
want to think about trying to encourage
be built out so as to support not only
ourselves but uh others as well
if i if i could uh partially answer that
and then also partially answer the still
the previous question about just general
ecosystem stuff but um
i'm actually from my perspective of sort
of the you know let's say cmb oriented
cosmologists and every i kind of feel
like
all the packages you would need
literally already exist in julia or at
least the ones that would make sense to
be in julia
um
and
um
but of course there's always going to be
little things from your old pipeline
that are you know probably python or
something so so in terms of like what in
the ecosystem i actually think um the
python interoperability if that were you
know made even better that could be a
big help you know so we have pi call
um
it's very good um sometimes there's
challenges with switching the python
version um it's kind of baked into the
build
there's python call which i think
improves that a bit um but maybe that's
still younger i haven't played with it a
little bit um but then the other
direction i think that one is is a bit
more lacking the calling julia from
python so we have the pi julia package
but um
there's these limitations about uh you
know using dynamically or statically
linked live python or super technical
stuff but it actually just ends up being
every time i have to explain it to like
a student or something and i list out
the steps and i just see what the steps
are i'm just like what am i what am i
sending this person down this rabbit
hole you know um
so so i think so stuff like that to give
people just this really warm fuzzy
feeling that they're not leaving
anything behind
uh
that kind of thing could help and and
the tie into the astral pie question is
that i guess
you know certainly large parts of
astropyte right now given that say
manpower we have in julia astronomy you
know don't need to be re-implemented
right now
um
but if we had just a really nice you
know tight way to call them with these
these interoperability packages
so maybe a suggestion of starting with a
a rapper library to provide some basic
functionality and then maybe some way of
tracking which
which needs would be worth sort of the
extra effort to make pure julian
yeah there has been a request to
implement uh
you know
fitzreader
in in julia but
i'm not inclined to do that again
i did the initial python one and i
really don't want to do it in julian
but it would be worthwhile to have
well i mean i think there might be some
ideas that uh you know might be
appropriate for for students who are
sort of getting started in astronomy to
have a here is a reference
implementation you know your results
should exactly match uh and there might
be some opportunities to uh
you know
make progress on that
um
science institute provides a lot of
software support for astronomers and so
if there was an uptake of dulia
at you know stsi
sdsci or other
institutions uh like an area that are
supporting astronomers i imagine that
would make a lot easier especially for
observational applications
for folks to take up julia
um
i've spoken to the people of space
telescope i'm also speaking to people at
nrio they're not really keen on moving
to julia
so that's kind of a problem
you know i really think we have to bring
in graduate students and postdocs you
know young people
and build it up that way and that's the
way we got you know python adopted 25
years ago or 20 years ago it's the same
thing
you know
the issue the question is who's going to
use it you know
it was the same questions we had 20
years ago
it's all it's deja vu
but actually fits in nicely to another
one of the questions
uh are there places where
filling in a gap in documentation or
making improved tutorials um might be
particularly useful so that we do get
the
the younger generation not to to waste
their time on a dead language but to
jump straight into julia from the
beginning
i have a few a few thoughts on that i'd
like to share right um
i i think i sort of echo some of the
comments from the other people that we
don't want so we want to make
astro pi and julia we don't need to port
the giant package ecosystems and
actually a lot of the packages are
already there
uh what what really is
i think quite lacking is showing users
the path towards combining them what
combinations of packages solve the
problem for this user and we should
almost go to the point of imagining
certain users are actually picking real
users and seeing what tools do they use
in their daily life as astronomers and
how do you do that in julia
um and i think a group effort from the
julia astronomy community towards
documenting how you do these you know
common introductory tasks and julia will
go a long way towards easy adoption
does anybody have
uh i mean i have some larger groups will
create like onboarding materials for new
group members
and i could see you know if there was
some group you know a ligo or a sloan
digital sky server saying that it was
large enough to make that sort of uh
investment that that could have a big
payoff not just for their own group but
that could be the the starting point for
you know other groups onboarding uh
lessons and such does anyone have that
type even at a low level for helping
people get started
so does the astro stats uh summer
program have a repository of of
tutorials that could maybe be useful
yeah so christian was mentioning that
penn state runs an astro informatics
summer school every now and then and
there's i think maybe 13 16 labs or
something we created this summer
they weren't meant as an introduction to
julia they were meant for you know
the underlying algorithms
but with a little bit of work someone
could could remove the gui controls and
expose the code underneath to try to uh
make it so that people who did want to
learn and as uh how to implement them as
well as what they do might be able to
uh benefit from that so yeah there could
be
i mean i know that some of us teach
classes and you know each of us has a
fairly narrow curriculum that has to you
know get a before b before c but but
maybe we aggregate those and collected
them we could have a starting off point
but
i don't know other slots
well you know the people part of the you
know julia astro group i i am doing a uh
a tutorial for the adas the astronomical
data now the software and systems the
next one in in october i'm going to be
an introduction to julia so that might
be a kind of a starting off point or a
jumping point for it but the idea is
those are you know software people so
the idea is to get them familiar with
with julia because there
might actually be able to
motivate for a switch
yep
i just want to circle back to this point
of um
like
that
introductory materials uh being super
useful so i have an example here in my
cmd collaboration
uh we got together and wrote some
introductory materials for students to
use
uh this was in python
and
the you know there's been further
developments uh
where you know the software has improved
but
we still point students to this this set
of introductory materials because they
can read it and then immediately start
doing research and so what ends up
happening is that every student
uh gets started on this set of jupyter
notebooks basically and it's been super
effective
uh so i think a similar thing could be
done for julia for sure and is that
highly tuned to your your particular
research group or is that sort of
generic to you know astronomy in general
so this was highly attuned to our our
telescope even uh but
uh
i mean i think that's part of the
effectiveness is that uh
they could use these things and
immediately get running with it
i think in julia it's not so easy right
to start
solving problems
well i think one of the i mean another
question uh that we had was sort of the
the
tension between the omnibus package
astro pi
and the you know here's one little
package that provides three functions
and
and on one hand for a pure uh
software development viewpoint i think
there is a benefit to having small
focused packages but as a new user it
can be a bit confusing because i might
need 50 packages i don't even know what
their names are right and so it seems a
little bit like i have to to bump into
something or know someone who knows it
and so a little bit of organization even
though they still may maintain their
individual package identity
if we had a
astronomy you know starting point where
here's the common tools we use for this
type of problem whether it be optical
imaging or radio astronomy or cmb type
analyses might make it so people don't
have to rediscover
um
you know re-implement only to realize
that something's already existing so
there could be a benefit to having
individual groups make focused
uh onboarding materials and then
aggregating them and
trying to build off each other
and making sure that these these small
focus packages still work together as
part of a larger ecosystem as well
great to keep them focused uh but yeah
great to make sure that in combining two
different parts of these focus ecosystem
we don't end up with
all kinds of issues well that gives you
another one of the questions which was
your traditionally astronomers uh
business were trained as learn the
physics maybe some math um and you'll
pick up the coding on the side right and
so you know when it was sort of
programming and you didn't share code
you wrote your own maybe that made sense
but i think increasingly now there's
much more of a software engineering
element uh and you mentioned things like
you wanted them to be interoperable with
other packages and composable and and
make use of you know trait systems and
and all those things start to mean it's
a it's a bigger ask
and so how do we want to be training
uh
new members of the astronomy software
community so that they not only can
solve a particular differential equation
but they can do it in a way that their
small focus package is going to be
interoperable uh composable and scalable
um
how are people making that happen in
their research groups
and if i can say something about this
um
i must say that
i've often had problems with my
colleagues and students
and because
they are trying to use julia um julia's
a common line julia's rifle as if it
were python's replay
uh they probably experienced a very easy
transition from ideals rifle to python
replica because they are very similar
ideal and python but in julia you need
to shift your mindset because
several things are really different when
you are using the replica for instance a
variable scope in for loops
the fact that
you are
encouraged to develop short functions
people coming from a python background
which is most of the students i ever
come from that background
find it difficult to use julia in this
way
in my opinion one of the very first
things that needs to get
straight in a tutorial or a lesson is to
explain the peculiarities of julia while
cleaning out any ambiguities with python
yeah others
i totally agree so i when i work with
students uh this the fact so
they learn python first
and that fills their heads with ideas
about how programming should be
and so
it's not like i i teach julia right it's
it's like i'm teaching the difference
between julia and python when i work
with students
yeah i find that you know python often
forces people into this vectorized
notation and excess memory allocation
mindset
um that that it can be very hard to undo
um
and to be fair you know i came from c
plus plus and i wanted to write
object-oriented code because that's what
i was used to and it took me a while to
sort of respect the the functional and
multiple dispatch style so that i wasn't
uh
you know just
just translating but i was really
embracing sort of the
the julia's style in a way that made
things better so i think it's a common
problem
um
[Music]
what are people like have you found
things that help
my approach would be to to start out
with simple stuff and just have them use
the you know the command line the repl
to just two simple solutions you know
when
python came out 20 years ago that's kind
of what we how i encourage people to get
started with it is just to use it you
know to do simple calculations and then
hopefully they would uh
you know develop get familiar with it
and uh you know start developing you
know bigger programs and so on so
but i i fear i see a lot of spaghetti
code and you know people not breaking
things to functions and and just you
know very simple things that if you say
oh just just get using it
you can write spaghetti code that's all
one long script and uh and so i kind of
want to try to preempt that and to try
to get people thinking from the
beginning of of how to write code that's
going to set them up for success and and
working efficiently in the future
yeah i think that's a much bigger
problem
because even people who are you know
i've tried you know teaching people
python and teaching how to optimize and
write good code and some people it just
takes them a while
other strategies people have tried
i tried an experiment a few years ago
for graduate course and exoplanets to
just assign the students
to turn their problem sets in julia
um i felt that it was a little daunting
for them so i had them do pear coding
and i felt like that actually
helped them you know
get learning julia on their own and then
you know using one another as references
for you know
couldn't figure out something that maybe
your partner could
um and that seemed to go well the
pandemic kind of threw a wrench in
things and
folks have gone back to using python and
existed trying to learn a new language
given everything else that they're
facing of course the haircutting's
harder when you're doing things remotely
but
um but it actually uh when it was in
person and the students were
you know doing their problem sets in
julia some really embraced it and wrote
some really all good
code and nice solutions to the problem
sets um and the nice thing about doing
that
in the course as well
is that you know the problem can be
solved and like in research where
sometimes you don't know it's a
problem can be solved for that
i know you did that too eric with your
um your medical competing course
during the the recent students have
opinions on what was helpful for them
i mean i guess like for me it was just
that i would you know using some
interactive notebook the cells just
finished immediately like you know like
that it was just so fast you know like
it was like that it was as simple as
that for me just being like oh i want to
do x calculation or whatever
um and it was like 10 times faster out
of nowhere um
you know than doing in raw python was
like the thing that made it like okay
this is going to probably be annoying
sometimes but like
it was already like from the get-go i
was pretty convinced um but i just had
to see that like relevant example that
was like oh i could see how in my work
this trans this goes from oh this this
code i'm running takes five minutes to
run and i have to wait and do something
to it is done in like you know 10 15
seconds and i'm already you know back to
it like that time difference you know is
what really like bought me over but
yeah um
well yeah i thought that the the real
time bit was was fascinating um and
probably has some pretty high
performance to me and i wonder if
there might be
i mean since since christian mentioned
how that made a big impact on them uh
does
does that real time angle and
interactivity maybe visualizing data
where it's maybe not quite as strict
requirement as a real control system
is there maybe some like data
visualization tasks that uh there might
be lessons from how you implemented the
uh control systems for
for making
fully interactive
i'm sorry i didn't i didn't quite follow
the question
i was still formulating the way i guess
uh you know christian mentioned that
being able to see things you know just
ins execute instantaneously was you know
a big win and had obvious benefits um i
know that one challenge is in astronomy
oftentimes you know the starter problems
when you're teaching students to code
they're all fast in any language because
you know whether it's a millisecond or
10 microsec
microsecond or 10 milliseconds like you
don't notice it's only once you start
working at problems that are you know 10
seconds or 10 minutes that you're like
well this is critically important um
and and
since you had that sort of uh you know
really impressive accomplishments on
getting you know millisecond latency and
stuff uh there i realized you had a very
hard problem with you know real-time
control systems but what about a task
like data visualization where maybe it
doesn't need to be you know 100 percent
real time but people just enjoy being
able to interact with their data in in
useful ways interactive fashion is there
uh
yeah the existing visualization packages
aren't really designed for that but i'm
wondering if that's something that maybe
you've basically been doing in that uh
visualization you showed us for your
control panel
uh yeah so i can offer a few thoughts
one is that definitely seeing those
real-time visualizations has been
something that turns heads even amongst
people who work on adaptive optics all
the time um but the the second is also
the the the code refresh loop uh powered
by revise that workflow and julia and
and for visualization specifically is
really powerful um to be able to in this
case you write you know you change the
code and you click a button in the gui
and everything updates you know within a
second of compile latency is uh is
really unique and actually that doesn't
exist in even other very interactive
languages for the most part especially
python
and so i think that's that's sort of
actually integrating the hot reloading
and changing how you're visualizing
something
into that
visualization sort of pipeline
conceptual pipeline is valuable um so
not just advocating for julia for how
fast it is and how it can make these
nice plots but also how quickly you can
move on them
on the fly is is really nice
i can imagine theorists who run you know
a
cosmology simulation for example being
able to interactively say like you know
go zoom in on this cluster or uh you
know recompute something including some
term right and having that same type of
experience even if it's not on an
instrument but still
enhance their science
you mentioned that was built on uh on
something i forget what what was it and
what was your experience using that like
the either the gui toolkit yeah
yeah so uh that is built on something
called deer m gui which is a super
robust way to make sort of engineering
type type which was originally created
for uh video game designers
um
and uh
it works really nicely in julia i have
to say that the current package of it is
it's gotten a little bit out of date and
we wanted some new features so we've had
to we had to fork it ourselves and do
some work on it that part was a little
less fun um lots of c call
so
i'd love to see some more development on
that package probably the person to do
it is me because i'm the one talking
about it right this moment
so yeah maybe someday
but
that that's so visualizations with that
package are
really dynamic they run at high speed
but because of that they can't be all
that complex
and i think for the sort of dynamic
visualizations as farmers and we're used
to mackie is a really good middle ground
where you don't have to start talking
about shaders and things and you still
get something that's fairly interactive
uh much more straightforwardly
and and that led us to another question
i had here um which was how do people
vet packages to use their projects
so that when people leave your team or
someone joins they don't sort of have to
start with you know fixing or
dealing with an unmaintained package so
are people taking everything as it is or
if you lost some uh
some heuristics to help them make that
decision
i'll volunteer that if anything hasn't
been committed to in the last year i am
i'm skeptical at this stage in julia's
development of the package you know
there are no done packages yet or almost
none uh
in python or something like that i know
we've used that comparison a lot if
there's a package which hasn't been
touched in a year well maybe it's it's
done right every functionality is in
there and it works uh unfortunately
we're not at that state in julia so if
it hasn't been touched i'm a little
worried that it's going to be touched
again in future
i know i kind of like the ones that do
everything i need and have been touched
a year because that means they probably
won't work against the next version
but i think you make a good point
there's a there's an easy thing to see
how actively it's being developed um
and i guess a year is a
natural time scale for really paying
attention to
um
there's also the blessing of being on
the the blessing of being on the julia
astra website
um i think we can use that as a
signifier of where people should look
for their you know they're just starting
out what packages should i use
well so that raised the interesting
point i think uh
you know on one hand you want to have
something that's it's a there's value to
be a complete index right where you can
find everything you need there's also
value having a highly curated you know
these are stable well documented um but
there might be things in the middle
maybe something stable but but not well
documented or
as well documented two versions ago but
there's been some upgrades so thinking
about how we uh
would
provide that information a way that
allows people to make informed choices
about what meets their needs which
sometimes may rely more on stability and
sometimes more on
functionality or
documentation
um other thoughts how else what are
other people doing in this regard in
terms of how to
how and when to include packages
yeah one thing i can say so um
definitely commit uh um activity is a
big one uh github stars you know maybe
it's not the best but we should all go
and and uh
and just start each other's repos you
know uh to help bolster ourselves
that's a big one and maybe
i'm worth mentioning in some context i
don't know but i feel like certainly a
unique thing of julia that i really like
is that if i find someone's package that
um
is broken or something
you know has some missing functionality
um
and for whatever reason you know maybe
clearly the author has moved on you know
something um it's i'm not gonna like pr
their repo to fix it you know the unique
aspect of julia where you just define
one of their methods in your package
to kind of fix the one little thing that
you needed um that that
gets gets you a lot more out of some of
these packages that might have you know
otherwise kind of been considered a bit
dead
[Music]
good
other suggestions
do you have a specific example of that
that you could share
[Music]
sure i think i i um
i might have even just commented on the
on the what is it pigeon hole um
christopher caucus asked about um
uh component arrays um
uh and those i think maybe at the moment
or last time i looked don't work with
cuda or with with like gpu back to raise
um
but the fix to make it work like 99 of
the way it's it's like 10 lines of code
and um
and you know so i could just put that in
my package and i know it works for
everyone now i don't mean to apply
component arrays is one of these like
almost dead packages it's actually
awesome and and uh surely it'll be you
know
maybe it already even has as of this
recording you know works on with gpu
arrays but um
but even if it doesn't you can
you know you can make it work with your
own code and then you know ship your own
code off to some collaborator and it'll
work you know it'll work for them as
well
without you having to go through the
time you know of a pr and everything
else and
yeah i've had i've had a similar
experience where you know i'll have some
subset of my code that's like i for for
example there was like a six line or
seven line function i had to wrote for
like some auto diff packet or for the
auto dip package nabla that i'm using
when it sees like a view of an array
instead of a like you know it sees a sub
array instead of a total array it's like
ah you know i don't know what to do with
that and so all it was is just you know
just a very simple rule to be like if
you see a view it's just just treat it
basically like a normal array right um
with the you know with like one or two
caveats but like
yeah it i've had a similar experience
where like a package will almost do what
you need and like
sometimes it's it's fairly simple to
extend it um
which can be nice but also it's like
annoying that you have to do the
extension um
um another question we had was about
julius package manager um and i guess
depending on what you're used to
uh it may seem like a gigantic
improvement or it may just be different
or you may have some some laughings from
from the point of view of the
astronomers uh on on the panel
what's their impression of the julia
package manager is that something that
they've found useful is that something
they wish uh had significant changes
i i could to hop in but i feel like you
could argue the package manager is the
best part of julia um
and
and um
yeah we could leverage that certainly
for you know onboarding new people for
sure and every time i go to python and i
have to learn which of the ten new
package management environments is the
best one and it still doesn't even work
as good as julia
you know
it's it's so nice that it's it's one
it's built in
it's good
um
i guess if i had to love you one one
criticism maybe it would be nice and i
know it's being worked on optional
dependencies
um
having that a little better
um
[Music]
other spot on the package major
situation for astronomy
did you want to go william
uh no you go for it
okay sure yeah i i was also going to
just chime in and sing some praises i
mean the only issue i've really had with
the package manager is if you have like
and this may be more of a condemnation
of my own workflow you know than for of
the package manager but if you have like
more than one unregistered package in
your in your dependencies then it can
really start to freak out um and like
you have to make sure you add them like
in the right order and stuff
um
but
uh other than that you know like we
recently had a new cluster you know made
at penn state and like getting my code
working on that was basically just doing
like an instantiate um which is like
you know way easier than other languages
i've had to do that for um
so
yeah
it's funny you commented that i would
agree with both of your previous
comments that the patch manager is
almost one of the best things of julia
uh and your pain point that dealing with
unregistered packages
uh
is is still a little bit tricky
obviously dealing with one pair of
packages is not a deal at all but if you
have an unregistered package that
depends another unregistered package
well just don't do that at the moment is
the answer and um
unfortunately i want to make more than
one package and not all of them are
always ready for prime time i don't want
to register them and so the answer then
is make your own private registry which
is okay but
it should be easier than that um
there's it's good to have a little bit
of a push to get people to put their
stuff in the registry so maybe it
doesn't need to be 100 convenient but it
could be just a bit more convenient
one thing i i
struggled with at first was what to do
with large data files let's say you have
tests but but it needs to work on 100
megabyte file to run the tests uh
and of course github has its file size
issues so so recently i found a couple
of package data downloaders i think and
and something else that make it a lot
easier for incorporating those
um so i'm going to try to use those
going forward but i haven't actually
incorporated into my standard uh
workflow yet so i'm eager to try that
out that could resolve the one remaining
thing that was bothering me
another question we had is is people
wondering how the development times of
our codes compared to what they might
have been in previous languages
and want to offer thoughts on that
that's all that's the entire reason i
like julia is that i feel like i
didn't write code more quickly but it's
hard to compare because i haven't gone
back and tried to re
write code uh and say in the mix of idl
and portrand which i wouldn't recommend
anyone to try but i know python and c is
a pretty
common mix right now
for my collaborators
um
i've had i've had difficulty convincing
them to use julia though and i think uh
you know maybe just the inertia of
doing what you know and and um
using that it's maybe hard hard enough
to overcome um that they're not really
willing to take it up i'm talking about
dan mackey actually
as well as um ridiculous to my plus
collaborators that
um did help with the limb dart code in
the duckduckgl code
but um yeah i feel like just being able
to you know if i if i have a bug and a
bit of code and just being able to copy
that and paste that into the repo and
you know be able to run it and figure
out what's going on
it's so incredibly useful and it could
never be done in fortran
um based on my experience i think you
know in terms of fairly computational
code i'm probably twice as productive as
i was with python
you know sci-fi and
for really highly intensive code you
know it's it's much
it's much better than that you know far
beyond that you know at some point uh
you know
sci-fi you know with uh c c plus plus
you know underlayer just takes a huge
amount of effort
you know
i mean we were aware of that you know 25
years ago 20 years ago when we were
developing it we were aware of the two
language problems but we were trying to
get people to move away from fortran and
develop develop better you know software
we thought python was you know a good
step in that direction
and to be fair i think it was
and
you know but
well
i think one of the big issues at the
time was there was
a lot of work being done in things like
idl which weren't uh open source and
there were licensing issues and
so i think that the transition to an
open source environment meant that if
you were going to write a high-level
language
now it could at least be open source but
to me that was the big improvement in
python because before like whenever you
want to paralyze something it was like i
have to buy 100 idl licenses to paralyze
that was a
a unfun pain point beforehand
historically
uh
25 years ago when
joe harrington and i put out our paper
for eight house we reviewed 25 or you
know two dozen
interactive data now you know languages
you know there was this language called
glish and there was python and pearl and
i mean there's just numerous languages
and so what we're trying to do is
instead of having these fork of all
these
interactive languages which were never
quite good enough
you know we thought python was you know
provided the best availability of all
the languages that people could coalesce
around so you know that's why we chose
python you know
plus it allowed you to have you know
multi-dimensional arrays which no other
language really allowed so
[Laughter]
for native julia users that's like wow
how did you live back then
one thing like in terms of you know how
productive i am i guess i think i'm much
more productive but the one thing that's
always in the back of my head um uh is
is could i be kind of just as productive
using jacks i feel like that's the
that's the one
like close big competitor i guess you
could say
and certainly one where when i talk to
other people in astronomy and i tell
them about julia or something they're
like oh isn't you know well i'm just i'm
using jax hardier
jax is the same and it's it's
um
and um
yeah i don't necessarily have an answer
there but just to to bring that up and i
guess to say maybe that um
you know i have some of my own examples
of doing i've actually played with jax a
lot i think it's pretty cool um
but ultimately i still feel like
maybe julia took a little tiny bit more
effort than that would have been but the
final product is better
um
[Music]
but it would be interesting to see if
other people have examples of you know
things beyond little toy micro
benchmarks kind of between julia and jax
maybe in astrophysics and and seeing you
know how does a real solution
um behave what's the runtime speed
what's the latency what's the code look
like
yeah i think the
for a long time you could make the point
the performance alone was a reason to
use julia um and i think jax has made it
to a point where if you're willing to
jump through the jacks you know hurdles
you can get performance that's probably
similar enough that you don't really
care about just how the performance
difference so um
i think the advantages of julia need to
be deeper than just speed but but go
beyond that i think they do but it may
mean that when we're talking to
colleagues about why we use julia the
answer has to be a little bit more
nuanced than it was five years ago
other thoughts
well i can add that
one of the advantages of julia with
respect to
either compile the languages as c plus
plus and fortune is that
uh it's far easier for me
to grab some code i wrote for another
context and put it in my new repository
in c plus plus maybe i've had a better
algorithm but instead of
copying it into a new project i decided
that it was a far
easier to rewrite it from scratch
because it depends
on
complex data types that i
i wasn't interested in bringing in
in julia it's far easier also because
the language
prices so you if you write a generic
function that just takes
whatever you pass it
to it
this is one of the reasons why it's so
efficient to write code in julia not my
only one but in my experience it is
important
good we had another question came
recently about whether julia astro has a
diversity problem um
i i don't know the answer i would guess
that it's probably
not a no because uh astronomy is general
who wouldn't say no
um but but maybe instead of just a yes
no question more useful if you think
about are there any things that we as a
community can do to help make progress
on that front um anybody have ideas
it's pretty clear that yes
julian astronomy does have a diversity
problem
i think we can all look at the faces on
this panel and to recognize that that
might be an issue um
probably you know for me one of the best
avenues for improving that is
just working with a wider and wider
range of colleagues and students and
helping to get them involved
that's my own
personal goals
i recently uh
thought a colleague rodrigo luger made a
really nice point about the benefits of
making clear incise tutorials
went that you know yes uh it benefited
you maybe the person you were
intentionally writing it for but then it
could also benefit other people who uh
maybe weren't your intended audience but
uh if you you know write something
that's accessible and and well done it
will get used places that might not have
the same resources as it say you know
major research universities where uh you
know you might have a friend who can
help or an instructor who has the latest
a little trick or something so i i think
that that was something that i liked
because it was very concrete and doable
and the kind of thing i would like to do
anyway but i sometimes have trouble
justifying um you know should i really
spend my time making a tutorial um so i
think i'm going to try to think about
that as a
in the uh expanding our outreach and
broadening our community angles more
the other part is encouraging that the
many people who are part of the julia
astronomy community whether we know them
or not
to step into more visible roles
you know i i'm personally aware of
plenty of people who might have rounded
out this panel who aren't talking here
today
and some you know explicit invitations
to those people my help
great uh yeah i mean my my method
involved nasa ads searching for papers
that cited julia
and uh so that was the the method for
finding speakers because i i didn't know
most of you before i started um and i
think we've had at times over 60 people
on on the the breakout mini symposium
today and so i probably don't know most
of those and and so maybe we can think
about a way to try to
find those people who are interested in
contributing we've had at least one
person express interest in contributing
to coding to help support some of the
the astro julia ecosystem and so uh
hopefully we can think about how to
incorporate people like them into
whether it's google summer of code type
activities um or maybe someone uh
depending on where they are and
you know location and career and such uh
opportunities to involve people like
that in our research programs
um
other thoughts
i definitely second everything that's
been said
great um let's see
other questions on the pigeon hole
um
we have several specific questions i
kind of feel are best addressed by one
speaker about one you know particular
topic
um so i'm hesitant to bring those up now
i have a question to bring up about
plotting or time diverse plot which is
something that's still frustrating for
me and julia i know there's been a lot
of discussion of this on julia discourse
but
um does anyone have recommendations or
favorite plotting routines for making
publication quality
figures because that's what we spend a
lot of time as astronomers doing
that's something where one nice example
or maybe you know a set of four nice
examples that people can decide of like
you know fj quality plot scatter plot
app j quality whatever i can imagine
could get a lot of copy and paste
i i i've done stuff myself but i i
wouldn't pretend that it's you know
meant to be
the authoritative how to do it but maybe
the the best way to get feedback and
more suggestions is to put something out
there
and say if if you know there's an
improvement
it's been a pull request and and we'll
incorporate other nice there's times
there's a tension between you know the
four-line version that gets you like 90
of the way there like i find i can make
a pretty good plot
you know without doing anything
complicated but then if i really want to
have like the latex y-axis tick mark
labels the right size and
like i end up making up you know several
lines of code to set things up it feels
a little bit
uh
i don't know intimidating right word but
you know it might be seen as uh
distracting people from the main parts
of what you're trying to convey so maybe
we don't need one example but a few of
them for different levels of
type setting paranoia or
whatever
it occurs to me that a a maki theme
could be an order
specifically try and
and and match a little bit more of the
styles people normally see in journals
um because of course monkey does give
you that level of customization
uh that you sometimes need but it would
be nice if it started something you know
almost where you needed it
yeah i know that uh i mean whether i i
haven't used maki much but there's like
the the stats recipes
um
i i sometimes use not for publication
quality stuff but just to get you know
what i want to look at quickly
and i i found those be quite helpful so
it would be interesting to think if you
could make recipes not just for sort of
quick and dirty plots but for highly
polished plots um whether that's with
julia potts or mackie or whatever
nice idea
for that for the time to first plot
issue uh if you do the same thing
basically the same types of plots uh
package compiler now lets you build the
syst image pretty easily so you can uh
basically have all your the plot
routines for your most common plots you
know for me it's like just scatter plots
right uh so i don't need to do every
plot of a person might possibly make but
with you know four little plots you can
build into a system agent and
dramatically reduce that time to first
plot pretty well and there's a few tools
for
you know more in trying to do it
automatically right so instead of
basically writing a script building a
system for that script and then loading
it um trying to to make packages
sense what could be pre-compiled
efficiently i've never tried any of
those but uh it seems potentially useful
for the the more general
uh goal of decreasing time to first play
one other aspect of the plotting is um
you know what julie provides is good if
you're only doing you know several
thousand points or whatever but
i've had data sets where i've had about
a million points and
it just can't handle that
there's just uh i think too much data
allocation memory allocation
it's it's a weakness
in my opinion i'm pretty sure i've made
lots of a million points
the ones i have took a long time
all right just be clear are you just
using like plots.jl or whatever yeah i'm
like trying to scatter plot a million
points yes
um make a difference which which back
end you're using so things like that i
would definitely try you know a few of
them before
[Music]
polishing and such i will do
clearly i'm a mucky uh proponent because
i would say definitely check that out
for plotting large data sets very
efficiently especially gl machi for the
big ones
um yeah
and that then it has to fit in the gpu
so there might be a memory issue that
like says does it have to or is it like
can you tell it don't try to send to the
gp i don't know
i'll be honest i've never i even had to
think about it um so potentially that
does exist but it's never been something
i've run into and had to think about
these days the the high-end ones have i
think have comfortable ram for most of
the things but i can imagine like on
laptop chips and stuff not having much
gpu memory and uh might
might not be a full benefit use the
integrated gpu on my laptop um so
whatever magic it's working
uh it seems to be working
ah thanks for that recommendation
um let's see a new question here
somebody else chime in while i uh try to
load the new question
i'll comment on time to first plot as
well uh you know clearly it does still
hit some people uh especially depending
on their workflows but for me personally
it somehow stopped being a major issue
in the last year i can't identify what
change it was or where but it's no
longer the thing that i look at and get
frustrated with
so i think that's good progress
well i think there has been lots of
progress in plots uh the pre-compilation
being smarter like things that used to
to be i can't do all those that somehow
i forget the details but i think there
has been progress under the hood uh
thanks to
you know people working right there
there was that thing where like if it
doesn't have to pre-compile like every
package every time you like first you
know enter an environment right like
that was i feel like that was a big step
forward where like you know if plots was
already pre-compiled it just like i mean
sure it takes i don't know 15 seconds or
whatever to do using plots but it's not
like the minute plus or whatever it was
before that
um so someone made a good point that if
you
the speed of plotting depends a lot on
how you're outputting it so if you're
writing say an svg file versus a png or
something so it's not just the back end
it's also
uh you know i forget what the name is
but the thing that the plot goes to at
the end uh also affects the performance
significantly it's the image format
ah there you go thank you
but this is this speaks to the need for
recipes because in python you just type
in like i don't know plot lots of points
python and there's some package that
wraps something that does it right and
you don't even need to think no brain
cells are activated right it's great
i love copy and pasting and stuff from
the internet into my science right
that's the ideal
but like so with julia i'd have to think
like oh okay i have to open up makey i
have to pick a back end
probably to think a little bit about how
to set up some stuff you know so yeah we
we really should work on these defaults
okay well so so that that's interesting
there's a difference between there's a
benefit to having under the hood
packages being small in focus and
interoperable back ends but but people
don't always want all that power
and so so even if you you you do
have the option to go there perhaps
providing some sort of wrapper or not
omnibus package but like a larger
package that that uses provides sensible
defaults
so so that
the first time you can just you know run
plot or whatever and it does something
that's probably going pretty good but
but maybe as you you sort of grow you
come to realize okay i want to go beyond
this so that it's uh
yeah basically providing good defaults
and also ideally i'm kind of thinking
like the way with the say once ppl will
give you a warning message and right now
they're kind of disaster you get you
know pages of compiler flag things that
say uh
you know
incomprehensible and lined 100 is like
oh that's the problem right um and
they're sort of working on trying to
make it so the error messages will be
more useful and easier to parse um in
the same way if we could have uh some a
level of
sensible defaults being provided that
would help us be able to go to want to
quickly might be helpful for
onboarding and uh and maybe for
ourselves also to just spend less time
on the parts we're less likely to use
yeah
maybe a good way of saying it is i've
heard this before but um
batteries included but replaceable
[Music]
i'll just to make the statement which is
maybe useful for someone but i i feel
personally feel like the
plots.jl plots the default theme does
not look like the plots we are used to
seeing in astronomy papers
um just as a statement do that what you
will
um
and i personally mostly just use
matplotlib through through pi plot
i mean is that just like we're used to
seeing matplotlib or is that plots.jl's
default is that like personally i don't
think they're you know i mean sometimes
i switch it to like a dark theme or
whatever
while i'm doing you know but
i don't think it's bad i think it's just
different maybe
there's there's definitely a little bit
of that going on for sure
all righty well uh we're coming to our
close so i'd like to say thanks to to
all the speakers who uh put in the
effort to help educate us about the tips
and tricks and opportunities for
improvement i think one of the things we
discussed as a possible uh outcome of
this would be to help you know
spread some of the benefits amongst the
julia community and maybe even attract
some new members so i hope that uh there
might be parts of this that in the
youtube videos you can refer whether
it's students or collaborators too in
the future um but also
if there's ideas for
whether it's a google summer of code or
an nsf uh you know part of a project
there nasa is working towards uh the
year of open science next year there's
going to be many opportunities where you
might could bring some resources
to the
various problems identified and so i
hope people will keep in touch even if
you're
listening on youtube not registered
reach out to
us
with either enthusiasm for for
implementing stuff or ideas for uh
things that we might should be
incorporating when we do find someone to
help implement them um and hope that
this will be the first of several
opportunities to help uh strengthen and
grow the julia astro community
any final thoughts
well said and thank you for uh hosting
and planning this symposium
and thanks to all the people online who
joined in uh again we've had 40 to 70
people consistently throughout and so it
was great that so many people could tune
in live and hopefully more will catch up
later
all righty thanks everyone
thank you thank you
thanks bye bye to everybody everyone
thanks